Huggers like on an yeah.
I wish because I don't have any need for
the back seat.
Three,
two,
one.
[inaudible] he's a gentleman we're going
to fuck with live on the day of net
neutrality.
We might not be broadcasting anymore.
It might be over.
I don't know how that works.
When does it kick in?
Right away?
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
That's a great thing about it.
By the way,
has there ever been in like a harder
time to be at citizen?
Meaning like it's just how much I had
never had to pay this much attention.
I know,
right?
Like come on.
It's like fucking,
we have to babysit.
It's like their children that we have to
like,
wait,
what are they doing?
No,
like where they used to kind of be able
to take her themselves.
Yeah.
Or seemingly could.
There's not one place where you can go
where you can get one.
Ha.
He shaking that before you all.
Should I not checking maniac bro.
I don't care if it's just going to
explode all over the place.
Give it,
let that fucker rest though.
The worst ones are those little small
ones that I have those Cayenne cleanses,
you shake those bitches,
they just fucking shoot up to the
ceiling,
et cetera.
It's all fermented,
so carbonated,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
but there's no one source where you can
absolutely get 100% unbiased factual
information as the news,
everything is leaning one way or leaning
another way.
And even CNN,
which I used to trust all the time,
they fuck up all the time.
They're always having to print
retractions.
There was some thing that was going
around today.
It's just,
there's not one news source where I can
say,
please just give me the unbiased
information with no left or right lane.
Yeah,
I get that.
Which is hot,
which we talked about beforehand.
But when there's
like,
even the idea of the New York Times,
what people don't understand it,
people don't understand journalism a lot
of the time.
Like literally when people go,
oh,
it's fake news.
It's like,
you know,
you can't print fake news because they,
you ever,
you ever have anything in the New
Yorker?
You ever be quoted in the New York
Article?
I,
they literally,
you talk to the journalists then two
different fact checkers call you to
confirm what you said and like,
it's this true,
right?
Is that,
and I literally,
this is in an article about someone else
that I gave a quote for and like,
did you say that?
Did,
and you can confirm that.
And they do that.
They do that.
It made every major journalistic,
uh,
outfit.
They did the New York Times,
Washington Post,
uh,
like name the big ones.
They all have,
they're not as stringent as the New York
as the New Yorker because near her only
comes out once a week.
But they all have fact checkers and they
can get,
and the thing is these institutions can
get sued,
right?
This is not a good example,
but it's,
it's an example.
The conor Mcgregor fight New York Times
wrote an article about the conor
mcgregor fight.
And one of the things they said that he
was covered in blood and rescued by the
referee before he fell through the
ropes.
I contacted them on twitter and I said,
you in
this day and age you can't say things
that everyone knows are false.
Like millions of people watch that
fight.
There was no blood.
He was not falling through the ropes and
the referee rescue them.
You made that up.
He was outclassed and battered by a far
superior boxer,
which is what most boxing people
expected.
That's the real story.
Yeah,
but you guys added a bunch of shit to it
so they to shade it,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
It's not just shading,
it's,
it's a straight lie.
I know.
It's not a cause.
It's not really,
it doesn't,
there's no listen consequential.
It's not a really significant moment.
It's not like a big moment in time and
the result is the same,
but their description of the result
makes you wonder how much other things
do you do this too?
How many other subjects do you flavor in
this weird way?
Their attraction,
because I remember,
I remember seeing you right then I was
like,
oh,
that's cool.
Like,
yeah,
and they,
they change it.
Yeah.
They were checking they even,
but they still use hyperbole.
Even in their retraction.
They said his face was completely
swollen.
It wasn't,
it wasn't a quadrant of his face was
swollen.
A tiny amount and a little bit of
swelling from a boxing match.
Not like,
not some crazy fucking Haseem Rockmont
shit.
Remember that one had an iron on his
head?
Literally the fun,
like maybe the craziest thing I've ever
seen in a fight.
It was this disgusting.
It's huge Hematoma grummond that grown
out of his forehead.
So if you could find that Haseem ragging
on Lennox Lewis,
right?
Was it in Lennox Lewis fight?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't remember.
Um,
but yeah,
it was like he,
he literally had to go to Dr Pimple
popper.
I'm like a doctor.
People lover.
That's hilarious.
Like that.
That was,
that was wild.
Yeah.
That was an enormous swelling in his
head.
He looks like a war criminal and an
alien.
We did the harder to do.
Yeah.
So if that,
you mean that's the,
I don't,
I don't disagree that they do,
they do shade invariably,
but shouldn't,
you shouldn't,
you should tell the exact story.
That exact story was really clear for
everybody that watched the 2 million
people plus that watched it on paper
view or more.
It wasn't something that you can get
away with bullshitting
about d.
Okay,
but do you do this wasn't a problem five
years ago.
Do you know what I mean?
Like it wasn't like it wasn't a problem.
It wasn't a problem day to day.
And that's the thing that I was yelling
at somebody yesterday of like the uh,
once Pete,
once Fox News created this thing of,
of,
of like,
uh,
extremely shaded shit and people saw
that there's a market for it.
There were like,
all right,
we'll do that,
we'll do that now.
And then everyone's,
everyone's reacting but they don't think
they're reacting.
But,
and now the New York Times is trying to
go the other way.
Where there they hired this guy,
bret stephens to write op ed pieces.
And every week there's a new,
like,
what did you just say?
Like the hill.
Yeah.
They're trying to be like,
they're trying to be a kind of moderate
or see both sides and a lot of people on
the left are gone.
Like,
but that's how are you seeing both sides
to like slavery or how we're using like
the fuck you talking about?
Like what's both sides of the climate
change?
It's all their scientists and not
scientists.
That's like those the sides.
So why are you,
this is basically appeasement,
I guess as a,
as a,
uh,
you know,
consumer,
this stuff.
It's,
it's,
when I was to get into this
conversation,
I wasn't even talking about journalism.
I was talking about government.
I was talking about the amount of
fucking work it takes just to be like
too,
like I can worry about statutes and
fucking the FCC and fucking,
uh,
executive orders and just like,
I never had to do all this.
Like why is this so much?
I don't know if it's,
I mean they would say like,
you know,
to be an active democracy,
it's only as good as citizens and all
that shit,
but,
but it seems like we're all more
involved and it's worse.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like it's way more upsetting.
It's constant upset.
Like it feels like havoc every single
day.
Well it's,
it's definitely not good and it's,
especially from the environmental side,
whenever a president is shortsighted
about the environment,
that scares the shit out of me because
that has repercussions for generation
upon generation.
Yeah.
And he's doing it for short term money
grabbing.
Yeah.
I like the EPA being essentially gutted
what they're doing in Alaska where
they're making roads and they're setting
up mines,
knew the salmon fisheries where their
monuments monuments.
Yeah.
It's scary because it's just,
they're just chopping away,
just chopping away and the repercussions
could be forever.
We have an amazing system here in this
country in terms of like the amount of
public land that we have and the
beautiful places where you can go and
check out.
All it takes is one or two assholes that
have a mine one on one or two assholes
that allow drilling for oil in these
places.
All they,
all they have to do is extract resources
from these public places and we're
fucked.
And those places are ruined forever.
Not just for your kids but for your
grandchildren.
For everybody.
Yeah.
It's like I hope he like equipment cause
there's gonna be a lot of fucking
equipment of these places.
Now.
That's the thing that I,
that curious about,
uh,
people that voted for trump.
Like is this what you wanted?
Like honestly,
like want a democrat?
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
I have a feeling I have a notion that
they,
they didn't like,
they felt excluded by like elitism and
going to Davos in the hamptons and all
these places and like the Aspen ideas
festival and Ted talks and all this
shit.
So it's like,
Hey,
fuck you.
But this is a,
which I get the notion of fuck you like,
but this is like,
dude,
you tell me that
Obama stressed you out on this level.
Like the level of trump stress that like
is just created in the culture.
That's what I was saying.
Like it's havoc every day.
It's like a fucking melee.
But do you feel the stress every day?
Do you,
I mean,
are you like,
do like there are days where I'm like,
I can't look at my phone.
I literally can't,
like a couple of days ago I was looking
at something and it was the,
it was maybe before that,
maybe two,
three days ago.
There are days where it's so,
uh,
it's so like,
like in the red for like cultural or
political toxicity.
Then I'm just like,
Jesus,
I'm like,
yeah,
this doesn't,
this is like inducing cortisol.
I think that's a good argument also to
stay the fuck away from the news and
social media for a few days a week.
Yeah,
there've been a few.
You see the people past couple of days
that like facebook exact span.
Like we've,
we've,
uh,
kind of torn society apart.
Didn't mean to,
whoops.
Yeah,
I saw that one facebook exact was
apologizing for what they've done.
They've essentially engineered people to
be programmed.
Yeah.
I mean,
we've,
we've essentially engineered this thing
or you're going to be addicted to it.
You're going to be tuning into it
constantly and the things that are gonna
attract you the most,
the things that freaking the fuck out.
So that's going to take prominence.
Yeah.
Uh,
but that,
you know,
there's a market that's definitely part
of the market,
but yeah,
it's just,
it's a bad idea to have a popularity
contest to see who controls the news.
It's a terrible idea.
And that's what we have.
And this is,
this is a real example of an old system
that really shouldn't exist anymore.
I had an idea that a couple of weeks ago
that it was like,
I got to run that by joe as like a
jumping off point for conversation robot
president.
Ooh.
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like logical,
super logical here.
Logic,
stats,
no emotions,
no emotions.
Uh,
takes all of history.
Human,
his other 2000 recorded history,
2000 year,
what are,
you know,
really 200 years but like,
and takes it all into account.
Even takes literature into account.
Hmm.
Like plots,
like take Shakespeare.
No account takes plots,
you know,
Hammer,
the ava,
all that shit.
And then wouldn't that,
isn't that kind of what you want?
Yeah.
Like in that kind of what you want.
And even if,
if,
if they say,
if the robot President says I've come to
this decision,
it was 55,
45 in favor.
Cause that's all like the older you get.
I'm not a hundred percent anything.
Like even though I really love Louise
Joke in his last special,
um,
which weirdly didn't make any top 10
list for the year.
Um,
I'm one of those weird things.
I listened to it on the plane back from
Hawaii a couple of weeks ago.
I'm great.
It's great.
The last I watched it actually the last
few bits.
We're fucking killer.
Just kill out the one about the
fingering and the Magic Mike.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The family.
Mine was great and the Finger Magic
Mike,
my bidding put,
damn it.
That fucking made me laugh.
Made me laugh.
So God damn hard.
I mean this is months ago.
This was before we knew anything about
the guy.
I did it right after I knew about them.
Yeah,
of course.
Uh,
but,
uh,
Louie did the thing about,
abortion that he opened,
whether it,
he's like,
if you,
they think they're killing babies,
I'd be out every day if that's what I
thought.
Right.
I don't,
I just don't see it that way.
But it's the idea of like,
there's so many debates that people
won't admit any doubt about like an 80,
20,
20% abortion,
you know?
Eh,
I wouldn't,
I would have one probably.
I've never,
never had the privilege.
Uh,
I've never needed to get one,
but like I,
and I think if other people want to get
one,
cool.
But I,
but at the same time,
I see when I see what your argument is.
Yeah.
I see both sides.
I think there's a certain time where
it's a baby,
you know,
a certain,
I mean,
certain amount of months in,
we're like,
okay,
you're killing a baby now.
I don't know when it is,
but I know what it is either.
But I,
it's gotta be at some point tell you
what,
it's not the first day when it's like
two cells claiming together and they
become four cells.
Just get rid of the cells.
And that's a wrap.
But you would even admit like I or maybe
it is,
maybe it is.
Yeah.
Maybe it is.
I don't,
I personally don't.
I'm not a scientist.
I'm not a,
I'm not a uh,
uh,
obstetrician.
But if we had,
uh,
like a soul meter in the room and uh,
like you woke up one day and your wife
was pregnant and it's like 48 days in
honey,
look at the sole meter.
There's a new,
so like,
Whoa,
Yay.
No turning back now.
Now it's an insole.
Yeah.
Before then it was just like a nesting
area.
Like they were ready.
It was a prepping area for a new soul.
You believe in,
that's at 48 days.
You're at one day.
There's no soul if you,
if you had a meter,
right.
If you had a way,
obviously we done this in a world where
the robot president and a soul mate and
this is all also in a world where would
they proven the existence of the soul,
which is just theoretical.
Right.
But if you could,
if you had like a thing in the room with
you sorta like when you have a pregnancy
test or you check like look at this,
it's registering,
it's real.
It's happening like a a sole meter.
Yeah.
So you have a countdown.
Okay.
It says I'm pregnant,
we have 47 days or were pieces of shit.
Yeah.
Because once the soul comes in
[inaudible] yeah.
Then then we're murderers I guess.
Something like that.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
But and there are people that believe
it's day one,
which is like,
I can understand how you think that.
I don't,
I don't even,
not even,
I wouldn't even say I don't believe
that.
I just don't know.
I just have no,
I don't have any feeling one way or the
other.
If you interview,
if you don't interfere with the process
from day one and it goes all the way
through term,
you have a human.
Yeah.
So how can you make the argument that if
you do interfere,
it's nothing.
Yeah.
It seems like you're stopping a
potential human,
something's,
something's happened.
Right.
But it's the,
it's the,
the foolishness of going like I am
absolute.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Anything.
And just the reductionist idea of it
being just a bundle of cells too.
That's so sort of preposterous to like,
no,
it's a bunch of cells that will be a
human being.
So you can't just deny the potential.
I'm not saying that a bunch of cells,
it,
I don't think it's any different than,
I mean,
I think if you can show me for sure that
it's four cells,
I think it's a complete total non issue.
It's when you get into three months,
you know,
two months in three months and I'm like,
Whoa,
okay,
what is this?
Yeah.
What is again,
as a baby,
you,
yeah.
To you.
That's your barometer.
Yeah.
But that's the thing I was saying is
like there's no,
you're not allowed to have a nuanced
opinion anymore.
You just have to be like,
no,
I am absolutely eh,
I,
you must believe all women.
Did you see that thing I posted the
other day about it was,
uh,
the me too backlash is going to come.
No,
I didn't.
And uh,
how's it going to cut?
What kind of backlash?
The backlash is the,
on the on campus thing,
the,
the basically like the Obama
administration and Joe Biden,
uh,
recommended these guidelines for title
nine and uh,
and they,
so they recommended these guidelines for
title nine,
uh,
the basically protecting women on
college campuses.
But the problem is
they throw out due process.
Like literally if a guy,
the idea is if your kid,
if you get a Qs,
you're basically convicted,
guy gets accused,
he's thrown out of school and it's like,
well that's not due process.
There were all these things that were
like,
like I'd never thought about before.
Like,
cause I,
I want to believe all,
you know what I mean?
Like I,
I want to believe it.
If a woman,
I don't believe women have much reason
to lie about the shit.
See what?
That's not not
true.
I don't believe that at all because I
believe there's a lot of women that have
grudges and they're angry and they want
to make things up about man.
And I know men where that's happened too
before.
I know men who have been falsely accused
of rape and the one that dropped it and
told the police that she was just mad at
him and she would,
she had a vendetta.
That happens.
It doesn't happen a lot.
I know.
I don't think it'll ever actually,
victor,
I just think that it's a minor.
I think it's just an [inaudible] or not.
Anthony Kumi has said something that's
really,
and he goes,
he goes calling all women liars is just
as crazy as saying all women to say the
truth.
Right?
Yeah,
that's true.
You're going to have a certain
percentage of human beings that are
deceptive,
which is why I say 97% of women are
life.
Ah,
no.
I think it's,
I mean,
I don't want to,
I don't even want to speculate about
what the stats are.
The is if you're a person
who didn't do anything to someone and
then they're accusing you of doing
something to them and then it ruins your
life,
that's devastating.
And that happens.
So I been having this conversation.
I posted it and I put on twitter,
Hey,
if I'm wrong,
if this is wrong,
yell at me here.
Go ahead.
And I was surprised by how few people
yelled.
No one really got mad because when you
see what the recommendations were,
people believe in due process and the
rule of law,
they should.
And they,
people know that mob mentalities are not
good and they're not American.
I mean they're not the spirit of
America.
They're there.
They are pretty American actually,
but like the,
they're not the letter of America.
Um,
and it was kind of baffling that Obama
and the administration,
so what's happening is,
so guys are getting kicked out of
school.
They're getting,
you know what these,
they're there,
the colleges are following the
guidelines and uh,
two processes thrown away.
Guys get thrown out of school to Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And then they sue the school and guess
what?
A lot of them are winning.
Yeah.
Because it's unconstitutional what the
school did.
So it's this weird thing of,
uh,
it's such a fucking sticky situation
because I was taught,
because the,
after I posted,
a few female friends of mine texted or
called me and one of them said,
uh,
that she was at Nyu and was having sex
with a guy.
He tried to,
uh,
put it in her ass.
She was like,
no.
She said No.
He said,
can I?
She said No.
Um,
and he did anyway,
she just froze and was like stunned,
frozen,
silent.
He finishes no alcohol.
No,
it's,
and it just becomes,
he said,
she said,
and it's like,
what,
what should we do in a society about a
situation like that?
And I truly don't know.
I truly am like,
I have no fucking idea.
Well,
if she said no and he did it anyway,
that's a real fucking problem.
Yes,
exactly.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
But,
but what,
but also then it just becomes what it's
a,
he said,
she said thing there's no,
and she said,
no,
we,
you know what I mean?
Like he real lie detectors.
I mean that's really the situations like
this where it's one person's word
against the other and the,
yeah,
the results critical.
You gotta I dunno if that's really
possible though.
I mean,
I don't know of anything that exists or
any technology that's on the pipeline.
There's no,
there isn't.
So a friend of mine jokingly said that,
that,
uh,
all guys and women need to wear body
cams.
Like cops.
Yeah.
That's kind of where it is.
Because again,
it is one of the like,
Shit I don't,
cause it might be you kind of think
like,
oh yeah,
no,
it's probably,
it's always pretty cut and dried.
It,
it,
uh,
and then you hear a thing like that and
you're like,
you know what?
I don't know what to,
but then no one's going to shoot that
guy get to be on camera.
Right.
Uh,
the now we're into like,
because I go,
oh guys shouldn't get kicked out of
school.
There should be due process.
Of course there should be due process.
Then I hear a story like that and I'm
like,
fuck man,
I don't know.
I don't,
maybe that guy shouldn't be able to go
to school.
I don't know.
I truly,
So he lied and he said that didn't
happen.
He didn't,
she didn't press charges or anything.
Okay.
Um,
which by the way,
it's super common.
So when you take into account rape,
the number of rapes that get reported
versus the number of rapes that don't
get reported,
it's like it's a drop in the bucket.
And,
and when,
when guys go,
well,
why don't girls report it?
Dude,
you don't like going to jury duty and
that's a week you want it.
You think a girl wants to talk about her
fucking vagina for a year and a half.
Not just that,
the stigma of running around knowing
that everybody knows you were raped.
Like having that feeling where people
are judging you or staring yes.
Talking about you for nothing that you
did.
No.
It's like literally as these things
happen,
uh,
because you read these,
the,
a lot of the times the,
it feels like the choice for women is as
it's happening.
It's like,
fuck,
I have to make my life about this now.
My whole life has to be about this for
at least a year and a half.
Cops,
lawyers,
fucking,
uh,
court dates all just like a nightmare
nightmare that you likely did.
Nothing wrong.
Right?
And you're just,
and now it's like getting,
it's like getting an a in a horrible car
accident or something that,
and again,
I don't know what the solution is
because as a comic,
my first and being contrary and I go
like,
well,
what did you,
what did they do?
What do they do?
All the,
all the things.
And it's like,
no,
most of these things are a wrong place
at the wrong time with a piece of shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
due process is significant though.
It's gigantic.
I know I to have it,
I know happened with the Uva case in
Rolling Stone magazine.
They printed this stupid fucking lie,
this crazy story that really becomes a
problem because there's real rape going
on all the time on campuses.
That's happened.
I for that that girl wasn't raped.
The UVA store.
Yeah.
I believe that she was raped.
I don't think,
uh,
it was the 15 like the way something
happened,
something you sure?
What do you mean?
What do you think that,
because I think they paved that she
wasn't even there and that she was never
in there.
There was no water or any of that shit.
Me Maybe then it maybe didn't read out
any follow up.
I think the significant,
there's,
there's so much evidence pointing to the
fact that it was all made up.
Yeah.
That does very little possibility that
something actually happened to her.
I think they've completely dismissed
that.
I think they think it was just a girl
just made some crazy shit up versus the
mattress girl thing.
The mattress girl one was a weird one
because she definitely had sex with that
guy and she definitely wanted to have
sex.
That guy cause she was messaging him
about sex and about,
you know,
I think she said something about bring
condoms and you're going to put it in my
butt and just a bunch of crazy shit.
Like it was sex talk back and forth.
Yeah.
And then she just decided this is an
amazing way to be a martyr and to be a
victim and to bring that fucking
mattress everywhere,
including at a commencement speech.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean that,
that's a different sort of case that kid
is now suing.
That kid is now suing the university and
I hope he wins.
Yeah.
I again,
I hope he wins and because I think due
process is as important.
It's literally a tie for first between,
uh,
protecting women and protecting the
constitution.
Um,
but
yeah,
I,
I don't even the,
the,
the thing that bothers me about even
talking about Uva or Colombia is it
makes the story about lying women,
right.
Which is just fucking,
not that they're the outliers.
Yes.
There are the outliers,
uh,
by an extreme because there are the
outliers must be able to come forward
ration when you can't just completely
ignore them in the equation.
Right?
Well that's the why you need to process
that is exactly what you need.
And you know,
we also have to stop thinking of it as
like men and women.
It's human beings,
human beings involved in these
situations and we have to treat them
like equals.
Do you know the story about Occidental?
Occidental College in La?
Uh,
I've,
which story?
Boy and girl get drunk,
text each other back and forth.
I'm coming over.
Do you have condoms?
Yeah,
come on over.
She comes over there where they have sex
with each other.
Um,
and then her friends convinced her that
because she was drunk,
she could not consent and that it's
rape.
You know what?
Remember that was a big thing for awhile
that you,
if you're not drunk,
you can't consent.
And it was like for a year or two they
tried to push that until they realize,
oh my God,
that makes everyone a rapist.
So they can mean,
having said that,
I think that the part that alcohol plays
in this shit giant is so fucking massive
and nobody ever brings it up as giant.
Yeah.
If,
if alcohol was complicit in all the
things that people did while drunk,
the same way that prescription drugs,
yeah.
They'd be out of business,
out of business.
So this guy and this gal have some sex
and it's consensual 100%.
But after the fact,
her friends tell her you couldn't
consent because you were drunk.
Yeah.
So even though he was drunk too,
so,
um,
people get told,
the authorities get involved.
He gets kicked out of cool out of
school.
She does not,
they just said they don't call it rape.
They don't press charges.
He didn't do anything actually wrong,
you know,
in terms of the,
of the law,
since
they're both intoxicated in willing and
consensual,
but they kick him out of college.
And so he's like,
well,
what the fuck man,
she's drunk too,
so I got raped as well.
Do you understand that you can't just be
the man that is doing the raping if
you're both intoxicated?
Yeah.
How the fuck am I supposed to be able to
consent?
So the idea is that this is as much of a
male versus female thing.
I had a conversation with a female
friend of mine recently,
and the conclusion,
one of the conclusions was men don't see
women as humans.
Whoa.
Meaning there?
And while they are here,
they're like,
okay,
let their other,
yes,
there it's other,
it's other.
It's like you're not,
I'm not saying you're not a human,
but you're not a man.
I,
you know what I mean?
Like there's some thing of like the way
men treat women is not equal.
It's just so it's other,
it's like you're in this other category,
don't understand them that much because
they're not one of them.
Yep.
And,
uh,
if they don't have a good relationship
with her mother,
it's even worse.
And especially if they were raised by
their dad alone,
those guys are the sketchiest guys of
all.
Yeah.
I'm generalizing.
I can't even think of one guy like that,
but yeah.
I don't think I know when it goes like
that,
but yeah.
Um,
I know a guy like that.
Uh,
and sometimes even guys that were only
raised by their mom or sketchy if their
mom hates women.
But the,
the whole thing is,
I mean,
look,
it's just real hard when you start doing
this men and women thing,
right?
Cause you're,
you,
you're prone to generalizations.
Just no getting away from it.
But men want sex from women,
so they pursuing women.
And do you have,
do you know any men that are,
that you're friends with that you see
over time to become more and more bitter
towards women because they be getting
rejected over and over and the associate
women with bad feelings.
You Associate Women with negativity.
I think men look at women like,
like they're trying to score on a team,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's dude,
it's first base,
second base,
third base.
It's literally like built into the
language of how we,
it is a thing that guys conquer.
So it ends up being,
uh,
I,
I liken it in the past to like Saudi
Arabia or like fucking towel heads,
but because they won't give us the
fucking oil,
right?
Like,
no,
it's there.
They don't like you.
They don't want to give you like they
don't what they are,
but that doesn't mean that they're
shitty any more than it means your
shitty.
If you don't want this fucking Kombucha,
it like you just don't,
your body didn't want it.
It doesn't mean that her body doesn't
want you like theirs,
but it makes guys,
it hurts their feelings and it makes
them crazy.
And it also deals with these
evolutionary mechanisms that are
designed to make sure that we breed.
You know,
it becomes like a significant issue for,
you want to figure out how do I get this
gal to like me to the point where she
wants to have sex with me.
Oh,
I got to buy the right cars.
I got rather where the right watch.
I got to do this and do that and say the
right things and be a gentleman and hold
open doors and all these things that we
do.
They're like,
well,
why don't men hold open doors do have to
be a gentlemen.
No t did show that there are
preferential mate.
That's what they're doing.
They're trying to con you.
Correct.
And to taking that Dick.
Yes.
The,
it's goes to,
speaks to your bit about invention.
Uh,
the thing that,
that your invention thing now is that
the reason,
the thing of like why women have an
advantage because they don't have to,
they don't have to,
it's also the way their mind works,
you know,
the hunter gatherer mindset,
it's very,
very different with the females and the
tribe versus the males.
And we're stealing,
still dealing with the echoes of all
that,
by the way,
for people that are,
uh,
shallow.
We're talking about misogyny right now.
Just so you know,
we're talking in theory about misogyny
and these are not views that either of
us home,
but uh,
yeah.
But,
um,
in fact the opposite.
I mean,
I,
and I have all daughters,
you know,
I'm used to being around little girls.
I know,
I know about women more now and
understand them than I ever did.
And how would you,
how would you,
how different would your behavior have
been 20 years ago if you had what you,
the wisdom you have now from having a
way different,
it would be way different.
I just would maybe might behave.
I never did anything horrible.
Um,
like my record is clean.
Yeah,
no,
I'm not talking about assault,
but what I am,
what I am more aware of now is the inner
workings of like a female from child to
adulthood.
I understand that they're just so that
there's a different evolutionary path
for their sex,
for their gender.
There's a whole thing going on that they
want to protect the nest.
They want to find a man.
Like there's a lot of guys that look at
a girl who wants a successful guy like,
oh,
she's fucking shallow.
She just wants a bunch of shoots.
You want someone to pay for everything.
But there is a evolutionary path where
the woman is looking for a man who shows
that he is capable of taking care of
things while she is held up being
pregnant and taking care of the young.
It is a natural instinct.
It is undeniable and there are some
women that are super strong and super
motivated and they don't have that
instinct.
Their instinct is to just have a kid,
give it to a nanny,
get back to work as quick as possible.
What I'll tell you what,
I bet their husband's tall.
You know what I mean?
There's still those things of like the
evolutionary shit that you can't get rid
of your body and wants to fuck a tall
guy for the same,
for protection,
all that shit
for all that shit.
Money tight strength provision.
Yeah.
And,
and the ability to overcome significant
situations.
Like whenever there's a,
like a God that falls apart under stress
is one of the most unattractive things
to women ever.
Oh yeah.
There was a study where like that I
think winning,
I have talked about,
uh,
where guys,
women don't like when guys cry in front
of them.
They say they want an emotional guy.
What they mean is I want you to listen
to my emotions.
I don't want you to be emotional.
I need you to be a fucking marine and
you're going to be emotional and cry
about things.
It better be like a brave display of a
emotion.
One of your fallen brothers.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
There's somebody,
you know,
like a baseball players retiring
something,
some physical,
some physical thing about the passage of
time in brotherhood.
That's it.
Yeah.
Maybe that's it.
That's my daughter's birthday party.
You're so happy.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the portfolio.
Yeah.
Um,
but the ability to respond to pressures,
a giant one,
the ability to provide is a giant one.
Physical features like having strong
features,
but having strong genetics.
The woman has to know,
like genetically has to feel like she's
being protected.
And then there's some women that don't
like that at all.
There's some women that like bitch men
and we know those women and they,
they,
they're the really domineering,
powerful women and they have these men
that are like quiet and there's sort of
tiring.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
that's okay too.
But these,
these patterns that exist,
they exist because for the longest time,
I mean,
look,
it's a weird situation where a woman has
to be pregnant for nine months.
That's a long time.
Imagine picking a man.
Imagine if you're,
you're a man and you're picking a woman
and you have to decide when you're
meeting this woman is this chicken to be
able to keep it together with me while
I'm held up,
literally held up for a year,
like a whole year for one year I'm going
to be stuck in this situation and then
from then the next 18 years I'm going to
be responsible for the infant that comes
out of this union.
Like that's,
that's so different than our thought
process.
It's so different.
The consequences are smashed.
Men only think about it.
To me,
men want sex.
They don't think about,
they literally and then it's just blah
and then it's just black.
Sure.
It's like sex and then just like black
into the distance.
Infinite blackness.
Whereas women do things,
which is why it's a,
it's a more intricate decision having
sex with somebody cause it is like the
long term shit.
Where's we'd just like,
we just want the baby comes out of this.
I'm not even,
that's the one I'm looking for.
That's when I'm just looking to come.
Yeah.
Women are looking for sex too,
but they also,
a good percentage of them at least are
looking to be a mom.
It's just something that they want.
It's a lot of,
there's a reason why there's 7 billion
people.
It's not because being a mom is so
completely unattractive,
they want to do it.
We,
I want to talk about some of the stuff,
uh,
with the sexual harassment stuff is the
stuff that people are not,
it's like the alcohol thing,
right?
Like I've never thought
drinking around your coworkers was
smart.
No,
I have like literally I'm like,
why the fuck would you want I wrap
parties I tried to get out of as soon as
possible.
Yeah.
I'll say for like a beer and then,
and I don't even understand the why a
company would have it.
Why would like,
I mean to keep morale.
Yeah.
They're not thinking in terms of the,
you know,
potential hazards.
You're just thinking,
oh,
it'd be fun,
fun way for everybody to cut loose.
A buddy of mine's producer of a show and
he and he basically a couple of weeks
ago,
it was like,
we need to have rules for engagement.
So he's made it so like there are going
to be no meetings where there's only two
people.
Wow.
Shit.
Like where it's like,
no,
no.
Everyone,
you and a dude.
Uh,
I think,
yeah,
I think there cannot be,
um,
I think two dudes can meet.
What about Kevin Spacey to,
uh,
Yeah.
Again,
that's just trying to go.
No,
I know.
Again,
which is why he was like,
where is it three people,
but he's the perfect example because
like he's just trying to come.
Yeah,
no,
a girl text me the other day talking
about how Kevin Spacey harassed her.
Really?
Yep.
Yes.
He's trying to fuck women too.
He just wanted that.
He'd like the power.
He liked the action it seems like.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Did you ever see his brother?
No.
Oh Man.
It's a trip.
His brother dresses like a combination
of Ringo Starr and Elton John and just
does a completely out there guy and just
talks about the Harz of Kevin growing up
with is insanely abusive dad.
And it was Kevin's dad too.
Like yeah,
I've never even heard of the guy rape
and just awful things.
Just awful,
awful abuse.
Well yeah that was like the same as
brother.
Wow.
Yeah,
it was brother dresses like that all the
time.
Like a Rod Stewart's brothers,
Ron Wood.
My goodness.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's his brother and it's just,
they just got fucking abused when they
were children.
Just fucking abuse monster created them.
Yeah,
that's what uh,
what's his name?
Morgan spurlock yesterday talking about,
did you see his thing?
I heard about it.
I heard about this morning.
You should read it because it's like
pretty like he,
he owns up to stuff,
which I get that impulse cause cause I
had,
when I don't have any big stains on my
record,
but I'm like,
well he had an attempt,
well he had someone accused him of rape
in college.
Yes.
And he also settled with a girl at work
with,
cause he called her,
she'll harass pants or hot pants.
That's whatever.
Everybody,
yeah.
And then,
but he was like,
I basically would just,
he did it like at saks pants,
uh,
like a cross in front of everyone.
And uh,
so she was quitting.
She basically said like,
I'm going to tell people,
right,
you call me socks pass.
Yeah.
You can't do that,
but you can't,
like in fashion,
everybody sort of puts their excuse and
the confession or a lot of people do.
Um,
it's like the,
it's the,
it's kind of like the,
I have daughters thing as a father of
daughters.
Yes.
Oh,
um,
well in that case,
well now I understand.
So I worked hard and that he was abused
and that he's an alcoholic and all this
stuff that was like,
ah,
yeah.
I don't know,
man.
It's,
maybe that's a different statement,
right?
It's no one will just go like,
I fucked up.
Right.
Hate admitting that they were wrong.
Like just going like,
I'm a hundred when p even in these,
in these,
uh,
apologies goes for the people.
I may have damaged,
there's no may.
You did it,
it happened like the,
the,
there's no,
I don't know if they do it for legal
reasons,
but a lot of the time it's like I,
for any anguish I may have caused,
what do you do that puts it on them
where it's like,
you know,
you did it depending on what the action
is.
Right.
So like if he's talking about the rape
in college,
you know,
you read the story,
what,
how the way he wrote it,
it's like,
okay,
you kind of did it when she said don't
do it.
So it seems like,
and then she started crying and I don't,
the way he told it.
Yeah,
it's not,
that's not,
it's like it
again,
this is like goes to that rules that the
rules and I've been doing this joke on
stage,
which is the,
um,
I have a nightclub or Jane that I do
Joe.
Well,
um,
usually got to come see it to you.
[inaudible] tonight.
I'd love for you to come.
In fact,
would you like to introduce me?
Oh my God.
Um,
I do.
Uh,
but I do,
sex is the most consequential thing we
can do with our bodies.
So we can't talk about it beforehand.
So we just have to get like,
man,
are you thinking what I'm thinking if
I'm wrong and going to jail sweet.
Like it's this huge thing,
but we can't talk about it.
But it wasn't a huge thing in terms of
like the communication aspect of it.
Until recently.
I mean in the 1970s in 1986 people did a
lot of talking before they fucked.
No,
I,
but I also think that there were women
didn't have as many rights.
I think now that women are like,
wait a minute,
women want sex too,
right?
Three man,
when we met each other and they start
making out and next thing you know,
they're grabbing,
Dick says,
I'm of the mind though,
that,
uh,
were women.
Uh,
it's in,
in,
in my understanding of women's nature
that Faye want mystery and they want
spontaneity as part of the package of
sex.
That's,
that's what literally turns them on.
Um,
mystery.
Mr. Mills mask like a car.
He got one,
he got one.
I should get a case.
Remember it tells all joke that's women
love mystery,
which is why whenever
my girlfriend leaves the room I'd take a
shit and one of her shoes,
um,
tell literally has a great one liner for
every occasion.
So funny.
Uh,
but uh,
the,
uh,
so it's built in to want mystery so you
can't,
we literally can't talk about it
beforehand.
You ever tried to talk,
you ever go,
you can't say,
hey,
I'd like to go have sex.
Now you have to go like let's go look at
my stamps or whatever that,
you know what I mean?
Whatever euphemistic thing you,
hey come up and look at my mattress,
my uh,
I got an egg carton,
whatever your fucking,
whatever your,
your ruse to get her up there because
you can't say you want to have sex.
Cause it's like about shame.
Part of it's a lot of,
it's the mystery thing,
but then there's also like women can't
openly go like,
yes,
I would like that.
Also after you date them for a while,
you can.
Yes.
Agreed.
Once you've done it a couple of times.
Yeah.
I think it's the longer I do this.
Yes.
I think it takes longer than,
than a few times.
Really good to get there.
Maybe that's you bro.
Maybe that's maybe that's on me Bro.
I'm always been weak bro.
You know man,
I ain't nothing but a bitch bro.
I wonder man,
I wonder how we're going to get past
this culturally I don't and that's so,
so what I've been talking to people
about is like,
so there needs to be rules of engagement
and like,
Whoa,
I think guys will be fine with
scheduling it.
The thing about the consent,
because there was a thing in that
article about ever,
that thing that they used to have like
at Antioch College like 20 years ago
where it was like,
I want to touch your breasts now.
I would like to.
I know,
but I believe,
uh,
guys would be fine with that.
I really do.
Cause I don't,
I think guys are like,
wait,
I'm going to get to touch a boob at 1206
great.
Yeah.
Put it on.
Like,
can I touch your breasts now?
Yes.
Can I take your pants off?
Not yet.
Okay.
And then you go back to making out.
Can I take your pants off now?
Okay.
Like you've seen that video.
Yeah.
It's preposterous.
What other answers die?
This port that see the guy in the video,
they may get like the lowest test guy of
[inaudible] who just like this weird
Beta male.
The whole,
the whole thing is just so strange.
I know,
but just if you look at this,
you know scientifically,
what's the answer?
You got to get to know people better for
you.
Fuck them.
That's a big one.
Like did the courtship like period
should be longer?
I agree.
I mean I look get Hawaiian and
implemented that in my own life where
I'm like I don't cause I don't want,
cause I know once I sleep with somebody
I'll feel guilty and if I don't want to
see them again and they'll be mad.
Yeah.
That's how I just try to park.
I just try to put it off for as long as
I possibly can and then decide do I even
want,
because a lot of times I've had like
friends and I haven't talked about where
you sleep with somebody cause you can't
think of an excuse not to,
you know what I'm saying?
Where you're like,
ah,
I did die.
Yeah,
I got to a place and then you don't
even,
you know,
you don't want to see him again.
Oh that's the worst.
You know,
you don't want to see them again,
but they're like going for it.
You're like,
okay.
I guess the problem is once you're
engaged,
once you're locked and loaded and yet
probably take this to the end.
Yeah,
I'd be a fool.
Not disrespectful.
Stair gift.
Horse in the mouth.
What the fuck does that even mean a gift
towards you?
Like looking at a horse's teeth?
Is that the idea behind that?
Like to make sure it's not too old.
Yeah,
but weird expression.
Stary gift horse in the mouth.
Yes.
How was that one still around?
Ah,
fuck.
It's looking at horses.
Yeah,
there are there.
Well,
there's a lot of things from Horst
Times.
Yeah,
that's a big one.
Uh,
yeah,
but so there is a thing of like just
wait,
but again,
that,
that's where male nature comes in,
right?
Male nature doesn't lightweighting.
Middle Nature does not like waiting male
nature's not like patient male nature
also is a testosterone itself.
B gets risky behavior.
Oh yeah.
And a lot of it,
some of it ends up in crime.
Some it ends up in fucking in,
you know,
electricity or the Wright brothers.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And it's like just harnessing it for the
right thing,
you know,
it's like the cause that like the,
the male character is,
it is,
a lot of it is some of the shit is
toxic.
Well,
testosterone,
it a lot of ways is power and with power
comes responsibility.
I mean,
but I say that,
I don't mean it's power like that
estrogen is in power.
I mean there's a fuel to testosterone,
the,
that when you have testosterone,
what it's doing is it's providing you a
certain amount of ambition,
a certain amount of desire,
certain amount of lust.
And that sort of,
that though,
that's the mechanism that a lot of menus
to get things going in their life.
And some guys don't,
you know,
I know a lot of men who are like
aggressive testosterone males who are
just chasing pussy and not doing
anything with their lives and they've,
they've become addicted to that and it's
become a major distraction.
And usually their career suffers.
Yeah.
Usually those guys,
they're their careers in the shitter.
I think we may be thinking of the same
earth and problem.
Um,
we know a lot of guys like that.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
I was talking to my friend Michelle Wolf
who just got an HBO special.
That's really good.
And uh,
but the nice ladies I where things heard
that's really good.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
and,
she was I with,
we talk about this shit constantly.
I was like,W men want power,
right?
Man.
Want to dominate.
Like that's our thing.
Like I'm going to expand the,
I gotta you know,
it's like that's capitalism.
That's uh,
uh,
that's,
empire.
That's everything.
It's just expand,
expand,
expand power,
power,
power.
And it's like men want,
it's the scarface thing.
First you get the money,
then you get power,
then you get the women.
And I was like,
what dude?
Do Women want power?
And she's like,
no,
they don't really.
Women want control,
if that makes sense.
Like they don't want empire.
They want you
too.
They want to be able to depend on you.
Right.
For,
I think fear is fine depending on you,
isn't it?
Again,
as we're going back to those natural
instincts that a mother needs the father
to be the one who's going to watch over
her and provide,
yeah,
that's it.
And that sounds sexist,
right?
People don't like that.
Well,
the woman doesn't need demand to provide
anymore.
I understand that.
You're right.
You don't,
for the most part,
I'm not saying that women aren't equal
to men in terms of their ability to do
things.
But what I am saying is there are
certain inherent instincts that we have
that are leftover,
you know?
And there's also like a lot of weird
shit,
right?
Like with this domination and submission
submissive thing that men and women
have.
There's also rape fantasies.
There's also weird snm shit.
There's a lot of weird stuff that people
have.
Yes.
That's just built into the,
into the,
into the operating system and your
operating system is probably going to be
different than Jamie's and different
than mine and yet there's massive
variables.
And to try to find them,
you're like,
I need,
I used to date a girl and she used to
want me to just choke her all the time.
She would grab my hand.
I wasn't on her more girls because of
your size would want that.
I whenever I see a guy,
a girl,
like you never see it like a tiny girl
with like just a monster of a dude.
Yeah.
And I always want to say to the women
like,
Oh,
you like getting fucking rail.
You don't like you fuck it.
Like to get,
do you like to almost get murdered every
time?
Huh?
That's your thick.
Some girls like that.
I would to,
yeah,
like there's a ton of girls that like
that.
And again,
and I think we've talked about this
before,
it's because girls never really saw porn
before 1998 99 so now there's the one,
the full like all the options and
they're going,
oh,
that,
yeah,
Chilean fun.
Oh,
that's what I want.
I want someone to spit in my mouth.
Yeah.
Am I fucking hair?
Wow.
Yeah.
Cause otherwise they learn about that
stuff while they're doing it.
Like a guy spanks him.
And I'm like,
yes,
but no.
And wait,
I mean,
wait,
remember when you spank me?
Well,
I want you to spank me because I want
you to spank me.
I don't want you to spank me because you
want to speak.
This isn't,
and it's like,
okay,
wait,
what
I did girl once who told me she wanted
me to rape her and I said,
okay,
but if you want me to rape you,
then it's not raping you.
And she goes,
and she was like,
she was joking around,
she was like halfway joking around,
but she had some weird shit.
Like she wanted me to grab the back of
her head
and force it on my Dick.
Like she liked that she got off on that
and I go,
yeah,
but the only way that I can do that is
if I know that you want me to do that.
Like I can't,
like I can't deal with,
but it's not,
I'm not like,
that's whenever girls want rough shit.
I'm like,
yeah,
I can.
I like,
I can get there,
but here's the thing,
like saying you want someone to rape.
The problem with the rape thing is like
if we just go through this,
are you going to fight back?
Are you going to say no,
if I keep going,
that's still rape.
Yeah.
Like even though you said you wanted me
to rape dude,
if you say no and keep going and
ultimately it just wound up staying the
way it was like we never went into fully
into the rave fantasy because I was
like,
oh,
super perturbed by it.
I was like,
this could go terrible.
Like you can't just,
yeah.
Also,
I don't want ever to get sexually
aroused by that.
I don't want to be connected.
Yeah.
Because I think that like I stayed at
girl and she used to like the rubber
feet on my deck and for a while I had
like this foot fetish thing going on.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And uh,
like I had it for years,
but it's,
she started it.
Yeah.
Well she was into it.
She'd like suck on my toes and shit.
She was a freak,
but she,
but that thing became like a sexually
arousing thing to me.
I look at girls' feet and I would get
excited about them for years.
Yeah.
If you had a girl who wanted you to
smack her around.
Yeah.
You know,
and I have a friend who likes that,
like he's into that and dates girls that
are into that and he's like,
you know,
like probably on their pictures,
their own website,
their own sam pictures of like bruises
that he left on them.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ dude.
And he's like,
yeah,
if it goes all ugly,
it's going to go real ugly for me.
Yeah.
Because it's consensual.
But what proof does he have that no,
I,
yes.
Yeah.
I don't want to get sexually attracted
to that and I don't want to,
I don't want that to be like the foot
fetish thing where you become that like
that's your thing.
Like I'm really into a smack and girls
around and holding him down.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause then you got to like,
that's what you need.
Then you'd have to go to craigslist or
you'd have to like,
you got an a toll on.
Yeah.
You mean you have to,
you have to like say look,
this is what I'm looking for.
Very specifically.
Is this cool with you?
I come to you with a heavy heart
dear Craig.
But then the problem with that is like,
you know,
how do you know that the woman wants
that every time you know there's going
to be tying now that's what I'm saying
about like,
Hey,
if I'm guessed wrong,
I'm going to deal with which is where
you need,
that's where consent comes in.
That's where like consent and I again,
because women are physically weaker in
general in men and,
and when sex,
it has to be them pitching it.
Yes.
In a way.
Like,
because otherwise,
especially if it's physical.
Yeah.
A buddy of mine who's huge,
physically huge,
a girl said choke me.
And he was like,
I'll,
so we just went like,
what does it want to nail the boat show
he won?
She wanted like a fucking real,
like real and he's like,
I'll kill you.
And so he literally was so scared that
he just kinda like put his forearm,
um,
call the ex boyfriend as soon as he was
done.
It's also crazy how fine get your choke
game.
Yeah.
It's also crazy how the law without me
yet like the how hard they want you to
choke him.
Yeah.
Like where it's like,
oh,
you really want,
I don't know.
I don't want to,
it's literally just feels like,
hang me off the roof.
Hey,
hang on,
hang me off the roof and then wonder
what that is too.
Like why does that feel good?
Uh,
well,
it's based devolution.
Yeah.
It consensual sex just started about
3000 years ago,
if that,
yeah.
I'm being generous.
Yeah.
3000 years ago it was probably an
option.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just out of respect your brothers.
Yeah,
I mean shit like it's,
it's just,
it's a part of like animals.
Yeah.
It consensual sex is like that thing of
like the universe is this old and earth
is life on earth.
Is that old?
Yeah.
It's a nonconsensual sex is this long
and consensual sex is it fucking tiny
sliver.
I think
the good about all of this stuff,
all this me too stuff and is that it's
going to force human beings to
reevaluate their behavior and that is
what
moves evolution.
Cultural.
Correct.
The ultra evolution is moving.
Yeah.
And also I'm fucking as a guy who roots
for the underdog fucking and justice
fucking fucking so happy for women.
Yeah.
So happy for women.
I think
we need in,
I think we need laws like unbelievably
brutal laws when it comes to pills that
people dropping drinks when it comes to
like the cosby thing.
I heard another story the other night
about that and I,
I just,
that freaks me out.
That's the one that freaks me out I
think the most because I feel like
that's like straight sociopath shit.
Yeah.
You,
you want this from some person and you
just feel free to grab something their
drink and sit back and wait and watch
and watch and kick in.
I had a girl accused me of doing that to
her whoa.
Terrifying in Vegas,
um,
Haida Chappelle show,
like literally to the,
almost to the week and uh,
maybe a month after the fear factor
sketched.
Jeff,
thanks again.
And uh,
and uh,
so meet a girl in Vegas.
She launched her sharp,
we mutual friends.
We meet for a drink at a bar at the hard
rock cafe or hard rock hotel.
And uh,
I get there,
she's drinking a mixed drink and um,
and uh,
a buddy of mine,
our mutual friend is like,
Hey,
I'm having a party in my room.
You guys want to come?
And um,
and we're like,
yeah,
cool.
We'll come up,
we have a beer,
me and her.
And then we'd go up to my buddy's room,
uh,
on our way to my buddy's room.
Uh,
she is like,
I don't,
we're walking across the casino.
She was like,
I don't feel good.
Like,
I don't feel like 100%.
And uh,
and I was like,
why don't,
okay.
I was like,
sit down,
like sit down at like a slot machine and
a,
and I was like,
I'll go get us drinks.
And she's like,
will you get me a beer?
I was like,
no,
I'll get you a water.
Like I'm not fucking,
so I come back with two waters and she's
like,
yeah,
I just feel like way more fucked up than
I should be.
Like,
I feel like I feel like somebody puts
something in my drink.
And I was like,
not thinking the double entendre of
this.
I go,
do you want to go back to your room?
And she looks at me and goes,
I think you put something in my drink
and runs.
And I chased her for like 10 feet.
And I was like,
I can't chase a girl.
Like I can't,
I can't chase this girl.
So
whoa.
How well did you know her?
Not well at all.
I met her on a Tuesday and this was a
Friday.
Um,
so for three hours I was like,
what am I?
Maybe I'm going to jail.
Like I,
I didn't know,
like I didn't do anything,
but I couldn't prove I didn't do
anything.
Like I couldn't almost,
it would be a move at that point to call
the police.
Okay.
And say someone just accused me and
putting something in their drink.
I absolutely didn't.
Um,
could you please do a tox colleagues?
She exam on her?
She might just be drunk and crazy.
Yeah.
Looking back,
thinking back now,
I realize it was at a casino.
So there's cameras everywhere.
Right?
Um,
but could the cameras,
the cameras have picked up me fucking
dropping.
Like could they,
maybe they weren't high resolution
enough.
What year?
2004 they probably were.
Well,
they're there.
They're there to like prevent stealing,
right?
Yeah.
And then gambling tricks.
So they must be able to see like your
hands,
they can zoom in,
I think,
but how you know,
how much whenever you see it.
Yeah.
It's all kind of like kind of pixelated.
But after three hours,
she finally like,
called me and was like,
Hey,
I know
because I called her.
I was like,
Hey,
[inaudible],
I didn't poison you.
And I don't think anyone would believe I
put like,
I have no reason to write poisoned.
You wouldn't do it anyway.
It's like,
it's not you like you go to court
because you wouldn't do it,
of course.
But I would have said the same thing
about bill cosby,
which you have.
Oh,
did I ever tell you this story about
bill cosby?
So I dated
or all?
Uh,
in like,
oh five,
oh six,
oh seven,
uh,
in New York,
beautiful girl,
mixed mixed race.
Um,
and cool,
whatever.
Great.
And,
um,
she used to talk about,
she some bill cosby came up one time.
She was like,
Oh,
Mr Cosmi,
what a sweet man.
And I was like,
Ma,
ma.
She's like,
Oh yeah,
one time I was on the street crying and,
uh,
Mr Cosby walked up and introduced
himself and I was like,
why are you crying?
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
and we struck up a friendship and I was
like,
he was trying to fucking,
just so,
you know,
I'm just like,
just seeing how he's trying to fuck you.
She's like,
no,
he's not trying to fuck me.
Like,
and uh,
and,
and like,
what are you talking about?
Like,
no,
it was trying to fucking,
again,
like I'm an animal for suggesting it,
like who you are,
so boarish why would you possibly think?
And it's like,
cause I fucking met the guy and he's not
a good dude.
Um,
and uh,
and so she,
she defended him.
He used to take me to place just all the
shit.
I'm like,
okay.
He just had a long game.
Yeah,
man.
And uh,
so then all this causes me,
shit comes up.
Then I texted,
I go,
so what do you think?
What do you think you're a boy?
And she goes,
uh,
she said something like,
I think like he absolutely did it.
And I think his wife was in on it,
which again,
I don't know what the,
what you meant by that.
But,
so then I were texting back and forth.
She goes,
you know,
one time I was supposed to meet him in
Philadelphia and he told me what to wear
and how to wear my hair.
Oh,
Jesus.
And she goes,
and thankfully I got sick.
She was going to do it.
She was going to,
yeah.
Wow.
That was the time.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah.
And He,
uh,
he was gonna take her to the ultimate
musical.
Uh,
and she,
and thankfully she got sick and didn't
go.
And I was like,
in the whole time it's like,
yeah,
that's the thing that one of the things
with some of these stories is like,
why would bill cosby want to be friends
with some lady?
Do you know what I mean?
Like what,
just because you're great looking.
Yeah.
Well,
I think it's entirely possible that a
guy could be friends with a beautiful,
again,
I don't,
even though he wants to fuck her,
just keep it together and just be
friends with her and,
you know,
find some interesting muse.
I don't think it's impossible,
but I do think it's not very likely in
my experience with humanity.
Right.
No,
it's true.
And also why would it got torched
himself like that?
It's like when a guy has a hot nanny,
dummy,
ugly nanny.
Yeah.
Fucking don't.
Why do that to yourself?
The hot nanny always winds up being a
pro.
Oh,
fucking every time.
No,
she's hot too.
Does she know Jackie?
No,
she's just sweats.
I'm sure they were.
Spends all day.
Let me pick that up for you.
You're such
a good dad.
Yeah.
Like just don't hire a hot nanny.
Yeah,
I would,
I would give that advice as well.
I wouldn't hire a hot assistant.
That's good devices as well.
The Fa,
I don't know if I ever told you this
story.
So,
uh,
so my,
I hired an assistant for the sexy for
the second season Chappelle show.
Right.
And um,
and uh,
interviewed a bunch of people and uh,
this girl came in super,
just like sharp,
just like I could just tell she was
sharp.
Uh,
and,
but she also happened to be good looking
and uh,
so I hire and Chappelle,
Caesar and goes word.
She was the most qualified and I was
like,
yeah,
she was the most qualified now.
I was like,
yeah,
she was the most qualified,
believe me now.
Uh,
and I was proven right because she has
since gone on to produce ghostbusters
and the heat.
And all of these movies and she just
happens to be good luck.
But it was one of the things,
I was like,
I fucking knew it.
I fucking told you she was qualified.
She's just good at talking about what
that girl you'd met Cosmin he wasn't a
nice guy.
Oh,
I met Cosby at uh,
our synea one time cause I'm a million
years old.
Um,
I went to our,
I met a woman named joy dolce,
he used to be in the talent department,
ed,
uh,
Arcenio and she was friends with Dave
because Dave,
you did our scenario and whatever,
whatever.
So she would like just go,
hey,
come by the show today.
This is like in when our CEO was on the
original,
like in 94.
So I went by one day and cosby was the
guest and he like,
and he just like kind of fucking berated
me about like he was talking about the
history of slavery and he's like,
and then the Dutch man came and he
pointed to me and I was like,
I'm not Dutch.
And he was,
and he just like didn't bite on.
It was like,
okay.
But it was just that he was just a
really condescending dude and I was 19,
so,
you know,
he had a right to be condescending,
but not really,
but
I'll whatever.
Like I bill cosby is a brilliant fucking
guy.
And,
uh,
but I just,
he's just not,
uh,
I wouldn't,
can I,
I mean,
know what I know now he's a real piece
of garbage,
but,
uh,
but the,
my interaction with them at that time,
it was not like,
wasn't pleasant.
And just seeing how he talked to people,
it's just like,
yeah,
this guy's a fucking not a good dude.
Well,
he definitely has an elitist sort of a
thing.
And I think that elitist sort of a thing
is one of the ways that he was able to
separate himself from his victims that
he's better than them.
You know,
he would behave in these weird ways when
you do these shows.
I've talked about it before,
but,
um,
uh,
I talked to these people that worked
with him in a casino and he would make
the entire sit down and watch him eat.
Yeah.
So all the people that worked in the
theater,
all the people that work the isles,
they would have to come in the room and
stand there while he ate.
Yeah.
Then he had,
he had a security guard,
tuck him into bed at night.
So he climbs into bed and the security
guard tucks him in and then shuts the
lights out and shuts the door.
Something similar to that.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
So he had this thing like I m p
superior.
Yeah.
I'm superior.
I'm bill cosby.
I'm Dr Cosby.
Call me doctor.
Yeah.
I mean the doctor cosby thing.
You should try me fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Oh,
Chuck d from public enemy broke my
fucking heart.
Cause on twitter he was talking about
like at one on the accusation started,
you know,
this is all a smear campaign against Dr
Cosby.
And I'm like,
come on man,
he's not a doctor.
He's not a real doctor.
Don't say that.
And they took that doctor away too now.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean I get Dave talked about in his
last special that thing like the heat
rapes,
but he saves thing.
Um,
Bill cosby's is an important dude to
black American culture in history.
He's,
well just culture,
but to culture.
Yes.
But he's the first black dude to win an
emmy.
He's the first black dude to do well.
A lot of shit.
Right.
And did,
did it the right way.
I mean,
he had an animated show to the people
forgot about fat Albert.
That was a huge hint and blind people
didn't forget about this.
Yeah.
It's hard to find now.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
and like just a huge impact.
And it was a real loss for black people.
Like,
so a guy like Chuck d who was eminently
respectable is like,
yeah,
there's a mourning period.
You know what I mean?
There's got to be careful when you pull
the trigger on calling it a smear
campaign.
Oh,
I totally agree.
And it's entirely possible that your
heroes a piece of shit and yeah.
And people can have both qualities,
they guess
amazing at something and very important,
but also be
terrible.
Yeah.
I have a,
I don't even know if I believe it,
but I had the thought that like Cosby,
if the kink came before the talent,
meaning I know I like poisoning people,
right.
How do I put myself in a position to be
able to plausibly poison women?
Leave subconsciously.
That's how people work.
I honestly believe that there's like in
the unconscious that you go,
I have this thing cause that's not a
thing that you just develop.
I don't think.
I think that.
And that's also not even a power,
that's not even a power thing.
That's some other shit.
It is power.
But it's like sociopathy it's not just
like I,
it's not like Harvey Weinstein is like a
to me is like the casting couch run
amuck.
You know what I mean?
Like I want,
come on,
fuck me.
Like,
come on.
No,
you're a hot actress.
I got power.
Like I thought that's how it works.
Yeah.
Like I thought that's kind of the way
the game was played,
uh,
with cosby.
I mean,
having said that,
a lot of harvey ship was just straight
rap.
So,
yeah.
Um,
but the fact that they were all
actresses,
I don't think it's like a,
a coincidence.
Um,
but with cosby it's like
that probably existed when he was 15.
I don't know.
I think it's entirely,
we,
I've been talking about this as well,
that I think that there was a time when
that was normal.
I think there was a time where slipping
a mickey into someone's drink was
something that a lot of men did.
Yeah.
I think it was,
we looked at things in a different way,
just like we look at hitting women.
Yeah.
In a different way.
Like you go watch those old movies.
The women got smacked all the time.
It was normal.
Yeah.
The leading man,
Steve McQueen would smack the shit out
of women.
Yeah.
Frankly,
my dear,
I don't give it to him.
Yeah.
Try and slap it a woman now in a movie,
you try it and be the hero.
Yeah.
I mean it's again,
what we're talking about massive
cultural evolution happening.
Right.
The also was that thing of like,
oh,
women aren't people,
right?
Eh,
there was some else,
it's a woman.
Do you know the,
what the real term for a faggot is?
What do you mean?
Like the origin?
Yeah.
What?
It's a bundle of sticks.
Yeah.
Right.
Well a woman was thought to be a bundle
of sticks was used for a woman.
She's burdensome.
Like a bundle of sticks.
Yeah.
Cause it's difficult to carry around.
So a faggot as a man became a man who's
like a woman who's burdensome,
like a bundle of sticks.
It was never anything about what does it
sir,
here it goes the archaic.
Yeah.
Take a take a picture.
We don't have to unit of volume.
Yeah.
So this a bundle of sticks thing was
like how men thought of women.
Like,
Oh Carrie,
this bitch around Jesus Christ,
you know,
bundle of sticks is annoying to carry
around.
So I got a question for you.
What do you make of
yeah.
With now that we've got Louis,
it's cosby.
I don't think they're even in the same
category for my own,
for just for the sake of argument,
prior beat,
his wife,
coke addict,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
do you think that there is a
correlation?
Okay.
Between comedic excellence and a
degenerate behavior.
Yes.
That sort of why I said it to the crowd
the other night I go by the way,
the ability jerking off on your stomach
and writing amazing jokes are roommates.
Yeah.
By their car.
It's like can I can't,
it's like a hey,
we need you guys to think irrationally
about everything.
Yeah.
How about Kennison here's another one.
Hix Yes.
And that'll hex wasn't it was
his Hicks,
the Derma deviant.
He was into
pornography.
I'm not,
yeah,
I mean like dirt bag.
Like,
like uh,
not malevolent,
malevolent.
I mean I feel like
Hicks is probably with more conscious so
we didn't do anything to women but you
know like friends who worked with them
and say like,
Hey,
we're going out.
You want to come out now I'm going to go
back and check off.
Like yeah,
it just,
it was just sitting to watching porn and
pten off.
You know,
it's funny I was talking about,
cause yeah,
we both Louis since you've known him
since 1989 probably I don't,
I never knew around them.
I would see him like once a year,
twice a year,
somewhere in say hi.
Um,
I know you way better than I know him.
Yeah.
Uh,
the,
so I remember when I moved to New York
in 91 and was in the comedy club scene
in 92 93 94 in New York.
I was,
I couldn't believe the amount of jerking
off that was going on.
I just remember her like,
why is everyone constantly talking about
like,
what the fuck is going to Louie's
apartment four to shoot,
uh,
movies like his shorts that he used to
make.
I would like pa on them and uh,
and it always smelled gross.
Like Jay Moore was constantly,
Jay Moore worry me and I were roommates
for a bit.
He jerked off on one of my socks,
like,
just like,
like why is everyone jerking off all of
that?
Just like,
what is the,
what the fuck is happening?
That's rape.
Yeah.
No,
you know what's funny is I was wondering
like today,
yeah,
I was thinking about the Jay thing again
because I'm,
I'm of the mind that like
again,
Louie was more gross than,
than uh,
malicious and discuss,
uh,
malicious and criminal.
I'm just gross.
That what he did.
I think it was just,
we did it to a man.
It takes on more ominous tones when he's
doing it to women.
Completely agree.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's,
I mean,
I'm not,
I don't want,
it's not a crime,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I don't think so.
It's just sad.
It's nothing like cosby.
It's just pathetic.
It's weird.
And you know,
w w has a crop,
some conversations with,
uh,
Eliza slessinger.
She was saying that men would say things
to her when she first started.
Docs wasn't very good.
You know,
she just started out and these guys were
like established guys and they would
treat her as if like,
you're below me and you're always going
to be below me and I can get away with
saying whenever I wanted to you,
cause you're less than me.
And she was,
and I kind of feel like that's probably
why he did that to those girls.
Like he was above them,
they were below him and it was not just,
hey,
I want to jerk off in front of you.
It's like you have to watch me jerk off
because I'm above you.
You know what's the thing you said
earlier?
It was relevant,
which is getting hard right from that.
How can you,
yeah,
that's the thing that's like,
but I,
but then it's also like you don't your
kinks and all that shit,
it just falls on you.
You don't pick that.
That's even a direct correlation.
Most kinks are just like,
I dunno,
like,
uh,
being hung off the roof everybody,
you know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
but yeah,
that's the thing of like the,
the getting hard thing,
but also,
uh,
fuck I the whole thing.
It is sad.
It's fucked up.
But I actually think he'll be,
he'll be in a year and a half,
he'll be back.
He thinks I'm stronger than ever.
Yeah.
Cause now he's got something to talk
about for,
yeah,
it's going to be,
it's going to be a lot of dudes at the
show.
It's going to be 90% dudes,
but I've asked the crowd,
I've asked probably five or six
different crowds.
If Louis was doing the show after this,
would you go and 70% of the people
applaud?
Yeah.
They would want to see what the fuck he
has to say.
Yes.
I think he should go on stage.
The first words out of his mouth should
be,
well,
I asked I there's,
I believe light should just come up and
he's jerking off.
Yeah,
that's a great idea.
And I'm just like lights down and just
like,
yeah,
I think what he did was freaky and
weird,
but I think Louie,
I don't think louise a monster.
I don't really know him very well,
but I don't,
I don't think he's a bad person.
He's always been friendly to me.
He's not a bad person.
Like
he's not like,
he's not a bad,
he's not.
He's also,
again,
I don't want to be like defending a sex
criminal.
If it's a power thing.
He the more powerful we got,
the lessee did it.
Yeah.
That's the weird thing,
right?
It's like,
I think he realized that what he did was
fucked up and like he had these crazy
urges and he did it and then as time
went on he stopped doing it and he's
like,
I'm a prisoner to some shit that I know
did.
And if he had just got in front of it,
I feel like if he had just a,
if he had just talked about it in a
letter,
men talked about fucking his staff on
the air and no one cared.
Well,
letterman just went straight.
Do you mean 100% confessional?
Yeah.
Which I think Louis could,
I think he just mishandled it.
Liked having sex with the people that
work with.
And by the way,
I'm being blocked.
I talked to the lady about this
yesterday.
He goes,
have you watched it?
He's getting laughs the whole time.
Yeah.
Like the whole time I'm getting big
labs.
He was brilliant.
Yeah.
I miss him.
But again,
the other thing,
it's like the irony of like Netflix
didn't pull his show.
Yeah.
But he was only having sex with people,
but here's the thing,
having sex with people back then,
but that you not want a piece of power
now that's can sit again.
We're talking about four years ago.
That's crazy.
You've got to rate,
it feels like it's changed.
What's changed?
Is it just everyone?
I think the Harvey Weinstein thing was
so fucking gross and he's such a monster
that everybody's like complete.
I think there's this ripple effect and
that we're,
we're like way beyond normal reactions
for things like Matt Lauer.
Yeah.
I'm still trying to figure out what Matt
Lauer did that got him fired.
He had sex with someone on staff.
Yeah.
I think he had sex with someone on staff
that probably felt like she couldn't
stop that.
That would be the,
that would be that sort of rub.
I don't know.
You see?
I don't,
I don't want a victim shame.
Right.
You don't know.
You don't know what really happened.
I don't know his version.
I don't even know her version.
I just know the third hand version.
You know,
like I read one that he had sex with
some girl until she blacked out and like
Matt Lauer likes to fuck.
Yeah.
He's throwing in his office girl sir.
And then the other thing was that he had
a button at his desk or you can lock the
door.
That,
yeah,
that to me is less,
uh,
rape trap then than it is just like a
fucking,
I don't want to have to get up and go
when you're the opposite that big and
you're like,
fuck it,
it's probably,
I don't want to walk 40 feet right.
Every time I need to shut the door.
Well,
it's also,
he's writing right when you,
right.
You don't want to be disturbed.
You're just like,
it's rather just let me just lock the
fucking door and lock it into this
thing.
I don't even think it was writing.
I think it's just like a convenience
thing maybe.
Um,
but there was no,
um,
the only abuses that he was having sex
with someone who was above,
below him.
Right.
There wasn't like he,
you know,
he didn't chase him down like harvey did
or you know,
offer them a Gig or another friend of
mine said some interesting in which he
said,
uh,
until dating people you work with is
illegal.
This is never gonna stop.
Yeah.
Whitney's got a great joke about that
that she's doing right now about working
in an office.
You know,
cause she works on Roseanne now.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's their world,
you know,
it's like yeah,
when men and women are in yeah.
And you can't like where are they going
to meet people,
right.
And you're working all day so it's most
of your day,
most of your life is with these people
also in the same way that they serve
like lunch at these places now or they
have like we play foosball and all that
shit at Google.
Like we have slides and ball pits just
like you can fuck people here.
Like that's what our thing,
one of our incentives were all allowed
to.
They will do,
they want to keep people on campus,
but as soon as you stop he make that
illegal.
Even if you,
if you decide,
okay,
our rules are you cannot have sex with
anybody you work with like den,
you want to fuck everybody you work with
then
show,
right?
Yes.
But you can't do it.
Okay.
That speaks to why can't you if you,
you,
but sometimes it does work.
Like if a man and a woman a working
together like didn't Jimmy Kimmel like
Mary,
like one of his head writers or
something like that.
Yeah,
he did.
Right.
Again,
is he a monster?
She belonged it.
Yes,
she was.
That's what it does.
I know.
That's the thing.
That's the irony of all this shit.
There was a thing at the Leno did his
last show.
It was like,
uh,
the 25 kids that were born to couples
who met on the show and I was watching
it going like this.
All the sexual harassments.
All crime.
Yeah.
These are,
this is a,
this is a perp walk basically.
It's not if the two people really in
[inaudible] water
comic,
no,
dated one when I was 21
I don't even really like sleeping with
wage on it.
Like,
I really tried to avoid it.
Like I,
I try everything,
everything in my power.
I can't say I've never done it,
but I really try not to.
Yeah.
Because I don't even think a lot of
times you're attracted to them.
I think you're attracted to the dynamic.
I think you're attracted to like the
uniform and like you're working and
they're working.
You're not supposed to and did a,
and then you see him off campus in
normal clothes and you're like
normal.
Yeah.
You go put your outfit on your apron on.
Listen.
How about you pretend to work at a diner
and I'll stop in for a coffee and then
we'll talk.
Yeah.
How was your experience with the dating
somebody but just,
I just think there's too much.
I want to be a comic going on.
We were both 21.
We're both,
uh,
both like really raw,
open.
My daughter's trying it out.
Didn't know what the fuck the future
held in store for us.
It was just too much comedy talk.
And I was like,
Gosh,
she's too much like me.
But she was fucking funny.
And,
uh,
she was one of the few people that it
was like,
wow.
Like she really could be like legit.
Like when,
when we were all open micros together
and it never worked out for her.
She's quit.
Yeah.
Gas.
I mean,
I lost touch with her about it last time
I talked to her.
I think we were both like 22,
23,
something like that.
And then I'd heard somebody ran into her
at an open mic night,
like a year later,
but she had never gotten out of the open
mic scene,
you know,
so she was in the open mic scene for
two,
three years and never figured out how to
make money and now,
you know,
just didn't have whatever it is that
some people have the,
the fucking driving ambition to,
to figure it out.
I don't,
the,
one of the reasons I wouldn't date,
uh,
another community is,
I don't like that ambition.
Pardon me?
Meaning like,
I,
I have it.
I'm,
I,
it does like drive me,
but you don't want to see it.
And I brought a cd out of it.
I don't want that to be my emotional
support.
The person who thinks that way I think
or feels what I feel in regards to
achievement.
Yeah.
Especially
like status and you know,
recognition.
Getting the recognition from your peers
and all that kind of crazy shit and
craving it.
And where are you with all that stuff
with recognition?
Yeah.
Um,
I'm everything right now cause I'm
pretty comfortable.
I was going to say,
yeah,
I dunno how you are with like a
congratulations or compliments or stuff,
but you've done really well for
yourself.
Thank you.
Like you've done like this is fucking
impressive.
I don't like,
I was just thinking of that the other
day.
It was like you don't get a lot of
press,
you don't probably do,
you probably get offers all the time and
just don't do it.
But you've fucking built a great thing.
Like a great,
like first of all to say like,
I'll,
I'll tell you a common with somebody
else gave you,
Chris Rock said about you.
He goes,
Joe Rogan basically physically willed
himself into being a great comic.
I don't even know what Chris meant by
that.
But I know it's common.
Like you just were like,
no,
I'm going to do that and I'm going to be
a great comic.
And you became a great comment.
That's to say nothing of all this stuff.
That's the nothing of like building an
atmosphere where two men can talk about
rape.
They were building and atmosphere.
Where you going to have me on?
You're going to have,
you know,
Alex Jones on,
you'd have a,
a fucking Neil degrasse Tyson on,
you're going to have,
um,
the,
uh,
Milo Yiannopoulos just having all these
people on and it's this weird cross
section that you built and it's all just
from like,
oh,
I'm into that.
It doesn't even seem that calculate it,
how to calculate it at all.
Yeah.
But it is,
but I,
but you deserve full,
uh,
accolades.
Thank you,
sir.
Appreciate it.
Yeah.
Wait,
really?
The man,
like,
it's really like you've done it.
You not only like you built an empire,
whatever,
but you've like,
you've,
uh,
you started with your voice and your
interests and worked out inside out.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm into that.
I like talking to people.
I like talking to people about these
five or eight things and then you didn't
and you don't chase.
You don't shondra chase too wealthy and
old to do it anymore,
but you're not like,
I got to know,
I got to know a multicam.
You've done a holding camp but I got to
do with this thing or I got to do with
that or I got to get,
but I,
if I was on a network,
I get billboards and I get all,
you know what I mean?
Like you'd get,
you don't do dumb shit.
No,
I just,
I'm into what I'm into,
you know,
and I did dumb shit with fear factor.
I realized from doing fear factor was a
great education for me.
First of all,
it gave me a lot of fuck you money,
which was great because then I realized,
well once you have that like,
oh you really can't,
it doesn't really matter.
You can really kind of do what you want
if you don't have to worry about how
your bills are being paid.
Now you have this freedom.
It's like if they cancel it tomorrow and
I'm like,
I still have this.
I didn't spend it all.
I still have a bunch of money and now I
can make a living doing standup.
I could do whatever I want.
You
could not make a living doing stand up.
You need to make a living.
Right.
You don't have to write you a,
you don't need to make a living.
You've got it.
Yeah.
Good.
Just lay back.
Yeah.
If you want to.
But I can never do that.
But I'm just,
I just decided somewhere along the line
like,
what am I really interested in?
Yeah.
You know?
And that to me is the key of like,
that's kind of where I've gotten in the
last,
literally in the last year.
Cause like the,
my three Mike's was popular and
successful,
like creatively and uh,
and like,
you know,
people liked it and critics liked it.
And um,
and it was the last year is the first
time I've been like,
am I funny?
Am I talent?
I'm like,
no,
I am.
So now I can stop doing shit out of who
you are.
This dumb thing that is mostly paranoia,
right?
Because when you find,
when people are like,
what you'd even,
what do you mean?
Am I funny?
Or can you write to her kin?
Like the things that I would actually
consciously think.
Um,
it's hard when you battle those things
in your head because they,
they steal,
they steal your perception.
You know,
they had such a waste of time,
such a way.
It's not even a waste.
It's,
it's maybe the biggest waste of anything
on our,
I like,
it's a,
it's your brain is,
uh,
it's an occupying force in your brain,
but it's impossible to tell that to
someone who's just starting out or who's
ambitious and struggling because like
that is all they want.
They,
they,
they so desire affirmation to know that,
hey,
I'm a legit pro.
Yeah.
And that's the thing is I got enough
affirmation.
It was three Mikes as popular.
Uh,
and I use,
this is how dumb the inner voices were,
I would think.
Yeah.
You can write sketches,
but you can only write single camera
sketches.
Oh,
that's so cool.
So then I was like,
you probably can't write multicam
sketches.
And then Dave hosted snl.
He asked me to help him with it and I
wrote a great sketch and I was like,
Oh God,
of course he can.
You could write with,
I know.
But I,
it might mean next town was,
I know,
I know you.
It was so obvious to everyone except me.
And then I was like,
and then the popularity of three Mikes,
I was like,
oh,
it's fulfilling.
It is fulfilling.
But it's also like you just check it off
the list of like,
oh,
okay,
I don't have to pursue this thing.
Like,
uh,
I know that that won't bring me.
It did bring me fulfillment in that it's
shut the voices up,
but it didn't bring me fulfillment of
like,
now when I walk into restaurants,
five people know me and that's changed.
Like that doesn't sound,
people love that.
Some people live for that.
I find that to be nothing.
That's a giant distraction.
Yeah.
I just find it to be like,
hey,
you know what time it is.
And then I'm just like,
I don't really remember it like it.
It's gratifying,
but it's,
I just,
it doesn't like,
it doesn't,
uh,
permeate,
well,
it gets to a place where you're like
Chris rock where it becomes a problem.
Like if Chris rock goes into spargo or
wherever,
like all a sudden,
whoosh.
Yeah.
Like all eyes are on him.
The paparazzi get notified,
the waiting out in front with cameras,
people inside or look and he's over
there.
He's over there.
There's the,
there's that level where you get,
where it becomes a giant distraction and
it fucks with your art too.
Yeah.
Because it's just as good about that
shit and that he doesn't have,
literally,
he travels by himself.
He doesn't have any boys.
Yeah.
He comes to the comedy store.
No body guards don't know shit pulls in.
Hey,
what's up?
I'm like,
yeah,
no,
he's very wise and the guard.
And he knew he had to.
Yeah.
He like,
I can't have people gas in me.
I'm smart of him.
He's a fucking smart guy though.
You know,
he can see the pitfalls in advance.
Yeah.
He's like,
which is why he's a great comic.
He's like psychologically aware.
He's not just delusional and trying to
push something that he's,
you know,
he's trying to like make work.
Yeah.
He doesn't,
he ha we all have blind spots creatively
and personally.
He has maybe the fewest blind spots of
anyone I know.
Well that's why he was willing to hire
people to help him with his act.
By the way,
that thing of hiring people,
because I worked on his new hour.
Here's what it is.
He likes comedy writers.
Right?
And when you're him,
he there,
you don't have any peers.
No one's walking up to rock and giving
them tags.
Right.
Of course would cause I know him,
but like most like he doesn't really
have like peers,
peers.
Right,
right.
Like so he just has come.
He's like,
he goes,
I like having comics.
Are comedy writers around and comics the
way rappers like gold chains,
he's like,
it just makes me feel good.
He does I to,
he just likes comics.
I can tell you in his new hour like it's
not,
I have a two tags,
another so premises.
There's none of that shit.
There's like literally I've two tags.
You wouldn't,
if I hadn't given them,
told them you wouldn't notice.
But it's also in the interest of making
the overall product better and so he's
willing to have a bunch of outside eyes
looking.
Yes.
It's putting your material against his
basically.
It's like,
okay.
How would you,
what do you have for that job?
No,
I think I have all the best beans
already.
Well,
what I was going to say is his work with
Richard.
Jenny was a agreed yeah,
I did too.
Yeah.
I think Jenny,
Jenny's the most unheralded I thought
one of them,
uh,
what was it?
His second pile of me steaming pile of
May was great.
And then the one he had some I remember
out of the subway car.
Oh yeah.
I was like,
I remember watching like this is fucking
good.
It's great.
Yeah.
I haven't watched it in 20 years
probably.
But I remember going like,
yeah,
this shit is really,
really good on a steamy pile of me.
I was just,
uh,
talking to some comics about it the
other night.
I'm my,
he has a bit about the difference
between the left and the right in the
center and you know,
and,
and I don't want to do,
I want to paraphrase it,
but it's fucking such a well-written
bit.
And he was so good at squeezing every
last angle at a bits fucking premise.
Oh,
just smashed them.
It would just be doing,
it would be obliterated.
And his economy of words was so magical.
He was,
he was a craftsman,
you know,
cause he was really fucking good.
Again,
a deeply troubled guy who never felt
like he got the respect that he deserved
and never got debbie.
Well,
he was in a,
I think if he was alive today,
he would be this huge Netflix star
selling out big places and he would
probably be happy with that.
But in his era,
that wasn't the goal and his era,
the goal was get a sitcom.
And so he used to do clubs where I would
go,
I would do the clubs after him and they
would be saying like,
oh,
he hates it.
He didn't want to do this.
He hates doing press.
He's bummed out that he's on the road.
He didn't move to Hollywood to be on the
road,
and I was like,
does he understand that he's like one of
the best comics it's ever lived.
Yeah.
Like when we were all kids,
when we were starting out back when I
met you at Boston comedy and like 1991
or whatever it was,
you weren't even doing standing back
then.
The goal was to make a living like,
do you think you can make a living?
You know,
you know what Jenny's only problem was?
His material was great and I'm trying to
think of a guy who is like this now.
His material was great.
His presentation was artless,
meaning he looked like he bought us
suits at fucking at the Dick Tracy
villain shop.
Like he just looked like he just had a
hacky sensibility.
His fucking bits were great.
Right?
There are people that don't like
Sebastian because of what I'm saying,
cause he's too stylized.
He's not stopping.
He's,
he looked sebastian shops at the mall.
Do you know what I mean?
Like to what he's saying,
he's just as my list.
He's not a,
he's not an artist.
He's not,
you know what I mean?
Like he's like,
he,
I once described,
I once brought Sebastian up as a blue
collar snob
and which is exactly what he is.
And uh,
and but like there are people like olive
arguments with people where I'm like,
Sebastien,
fucking great.
And they're like,
he doesn't need a little hacky.
I'm like,
no,
he's not.
He's not hockey at all.
But because he dresses like a fucking
Italian of fucking choose from Chicago
to,
he'd where's vast people literally
people deduct points.
They don't even know.
They're not even aware they're doing it.
Yeah.
And Jenny suffered from that were where
you had to go,
boy,
this is a fucking good bit.
Like this is like in terms of writing
wise,
like he was as good a bit writer is
Hicks was like
that are way better.
Again,
he better in terms of humor,
in terms of humor.
I don't even think they're close,
but I'm saying in terms of his peers at
the time.
But I mean if you listen to Hicks,
you're not going to laugh a lot.
Listen to a steaming pile of me.
You're going to F I was in the car
coming back from the Irvine Improv
before I filmed my last comedy special.
I was prepping for the comedy special
and one of the things I like to do,
I like do Irvine's big place,
get everything tight,
give us a full weekend.
And,
and uh,
as I was driving home I said,
let me listen to some Richard Jeni and I
listened to steamy pile,
me and I hadn't heard in years and it
was from 2007,
I believe.
And I was fucking crying,
laughing,
clapping in my car.
I myself on the way home.
Yeah,
I think he was one of the best ever.
And I think Hicks is a great comic.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean he's one of the most influential
and important guys ever.
But in terms of like humor,
value,
right.
I think Richard,
Jenny's above you put jenny like closer
to Carlin.
Yes.
Yeah.
I put it again,
Carlin.
Wow.
That's to me.
Yeah,
that's fine.
In terms of like,
I kind of think rock might to rock
fucking adored Jenny.
Uh,
the
you but people deduct points cause it
seems like because he worked,
because he had her within his voice,
like,
and Carlin would wear fucking a tee
shirt and like down,
like I'm a workman artist.
Whereas like Jenny was like,
are you,
what are you going for the dentist?
Yeah.
Like duty.
And like his,
his,
and he's like a foreign needs like Tan
and he's got his Harris come back and
it's like he had a lot of plastic
surgery too.
He kind of went a little bit nutty and
tried to become a leading man.
And yeah,
he had a lot of issues,
but the comedy was fucking genius,
man.
Yeah.
But people do judge like people the way
they look,
you know,
like it's,
it's a weird thing,
you know,
like Whitney and her last special HBO
special,
she wore hair down and she said that was
like a big issue.
Always wears her hair up.
She like,
and if they wanted to wear,
and Chris wanted her to wear her hair
down and she's like,
ah,
I just put it on it.
And I was like,
you should wear your hair up.
And she do you wear your hair up?
Well,
Tom,
argument rock was saying he wanted her
hair down.
He at,
by the way,
rock didn't say it.
He'd practice,
said it to someone at Hbo like,
Oh,
she could wear her hair down.
He wasn't lying.
I demand hello,
this is Chris Rock.
He was like,
just,
she's wearing hair down.
Uh,
his thing was,
uh,
she reads too hard on camera with her
hair pulled back.
It's all,
and her delivery is so like,
Gotcha.
The menacing is the wrong word,
but like,
it's,
it's like very forceful.
Kibbeh see that's what I like.
Right.
I liked the fact that she's like,
I'm pulling my fucking hair up.
No nonsense.
Yeah,
no bullshit.
It was seeing it more from a,
uh,
just a point of view of like a stent.
A director.
Yeah.
Just like,
cause dude,
it matters.
It does matter.
It matters more than you think,
but it matters more I think for the
person delivering it.
They feel comfortable and I think
because she's a beautiful woman,
I think for her pulling their hair out
because like,
I'm not accentuating that at all.
I just want you to listen to what I have
to say.
Yeah.
And that's the best way to do it.
You know,
like there's parallels.
I mean like,
like if you saw a really funny woman,
but she was dressing like a prime time,
Megan Kelly on Fox with little tiny
skirts on or boob showing,
it's like,
yeah,
what are you selling?
Like you're selling something different
than just,
I'm a standup comic.
Like you're,
you're selling,
I'm,
I'm a sexy lady out for a night on the
town,
but I'm also going to tell you some
jokes.
Gas Message.
Yeah.
But the,
the thing that people don't take into
account sometimes it's like,
you know,
a lot of the successful male comics are
good looking posh is fucking good luck.
He's a handsome fella,
but weird gay tones.
Right?
Fine.
That's a small price to pay for those
looks.
You get a fucking face.
I love Taj.
But the reason why I said that was like
Doug,
Stan hope who's a fucking maniac wrote
something crazy about tosh in his book.
Just you can just fucking with him.
I forget it was the murders women who
uh,
that's funny.
Question is sexuality like Stan hope
went semi hunters Thompson and some of
his stuff.
That's correct.
Clearly,
obviously he's making things up.
You have to be,
it's you have to be obviously wear,
but yeah,
Tasha is obviously a good looking guy.
Sebastian a beautiful man.
Um,
Dave,
Dave Chapelle.
Chapelle.
Yes.
Yeah.
He,
I think he was better looking skinny.
Really?
Yeah.
Personally it was more my speech.
Got Some fucking guns now.
Yeah.
Um,
like there's not like,
cause he was good looking prior look
like something like nothing I think
looks Maine like mean more than people
take into account.
It's like I always say to people,
no one with gray hair has ever made it
as a comic.
Not Never,
but almost never
think about it.
Steve Martin and Rodney are my list.
Hm.
Rodney was a cartoon.
Old Man.
I think there's something about being
old though.
You lose,
you'll lose your exuberance and your
enthusiasm and then the people are,
you know,
that's a part of the aging process.
And it depends on how much you cultivate
your own personal energy.
Yeah.
How much are you paying attention to
that or how well you taking care of your
body?
You know,
like more impressed
if you can come to these conclusions in
26 years.
Yeah.
But you can't,
well you people in essence,
yeah.
Yeah.
But like drawn white is a gray haired
guy now.
It means that the newest cities
spin and he's like a cartoon alcoholic.
Yeah.
And a real alcoholic.
He's the jet.
And the funny shit,
that motherfucker,
that motherfucker is so funny.
I said to him,
uh,
I was like,
Hey,
he did a joke.
He did a joke that like,
and I go,
d remembered that joke.
Where are you talking about?
You're in a,
in a fight with your wife and you said
some.
And he goes like,
I don't remember.
And it's like,
you don't remember.
That's a fucking,
He was telling us a story in the back
room of the comedy store.
Uh,
you know the back bar?
Yeah.
He was telling us a story and I'm
fucking literally,
by the way it will heat.
I'd seen him do it six weeks earlier and
he was like,
I don't remember.
I was,
he was telling a story and I was crying
like tears rolling down my face and I
forget who else was with us.
And I go,
you got to tell that on stage.
He goes,
yeah,
thank [inaudible] please tell that story
on stage please.
And he goes,
man,
I dunno.
I go,
just fucking tell it.
It's going to kill.
He went on stage with it that night.
He's like,
got a bottle of Tequila,
he pours himself out of the drink,
literally goes from the back bar to the
stage and closes with that.
Yeah.
Closes with it and it smashes.
Part,
I think I may have seen a bit of it,
Jeff,
by the way.
Jeffrey's Jim went on,
he'd decent.
Jim's not badly.
I mean,
it's like whatever,
it's a good looking guy.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
Jeffrey's went on the other night,
like he was drunk,
he'd been drinking all day and his
friend was like,
can you do standup drunk?
And he's like,
yeah.
well,
I don't believe whatever.
And like Jeffrey's went on and fucking
murder for half an hour,
just like drunk.
It can be done.
God bless you.
Yeah.
I mean,
especially if you're feeling it.
Yeah.
You know,
I feel like you,
you like sometimes being drunk,
like as long as the momentum's in the
right way,
you know,
like you're thinking in a good way and
everything comes out in your other set
of Jack got some fucking shit to talk
about.
Yeah.
Hey,
we go.
Yeah.
And then he goes into his act.
You don't really do drink much.
A little bit.
Yeah.
No,
not before go on stage.
Very,
very rarely I have,
it's not good.
Right.
I like a drink.
Maybe two drinks,
you know,
it would get a little tipsy.
Yeah.
But um,
being drunk on stage,
it's like not,
it's not the right way to manage the
ideas,
but it is a good way to not give a fuck.
So like if you have an idea and you feel
so strongly about it and you,
you're,
I mean obviously so varies depending
upon where you are in your life and
where you are with the material.
But sometimes some material just needs a
little bit of,
I don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
and then if you have a couple of drinks
for,
you talk about that subject and you're
like,
well,
why the fuck do I have to pay attention
at us?
And then you'd gets in a new place.
It's truly like jogs the,
where it's like,
here's
the fucking wall they hit this wall is a
door and you're like,
oh fuck.
All right.
Talking some real shit.
Why I'm a big believer in using as many
different methods as possible to explore
ideas,
whether it's the sensory deprivation
tank or pod or psychedelics or booze or,
or just going places and doing things.
And I think as I've gotten older and I
am on a schedule to put out a special
every year and a half or so,
two years now,
I think it's like,
my last one was in October,
so my last one was a year and a couple
of months and I'm getting ready to film
it in April.
So it'll be about a year and a half.
That's a,
to me,
he's like a good schedule came out in
October or you shut it,
came out in October,
shot it in June.
So from shoot to shoot it's about two
years.
Um,
I feel like that is,
if to do that I have to do things.
You have to have to have experiences.
I have to,
I have to force,
I have to not force myself to,
but I have to be consciously aware of
being an action.
Yeah.
Things have to happen.
And like I'm going to Vancouver next
week to do the Boga.
Oh Shit.
Uh,
and then the weekend for that I'm going
to Bangkok is ibogaine illegal in
Vancouver.
It is beautiful.
It should be everywhere.
Yeah.
It's not something that kills people.
So it's supposed to be amazing for
curing addictions.
Yeah.
That's,
I'm just going to see what it does for
depression because it's gotten way
better,
like in the last year.
Uh,
it,
the depression has gotten better.
And uh,
which again is the weird thing from,
I hate to say that having a successful
special cured my depression,
but you hate,
I don't want it to be that linear,
but it made me,
it just got me out of fucking negative
thinking.
Isn't that funny?
But I don't,
I don't think there's anything wrong
with you saying that because I think
there's a real stigma between
correlating,
having a success and achievement and
being happy.
Yeah.
But Ari Shaffir is a great example of
that I think are,
there was a chemical issue too.
You know,
Ari was on Propecia for awhile and I'm
holding on.
Yeah.
Well he,
he,
he let go.
He got off of it.
But one of the side effects of Propecia
is pretty severe depression.
Yeah.
Um,
our,
he got on some psych meds,
he got on some antidepressants,
then his career took off and he weaned
himself off the antidepressants and he
doesn't need them anymore.
Maybe they,
ours one of the happiest guys I know.
Yeah.
But he's also very successful.
And that's,
you know,
last five years of his life,
like money,
you know,
money can't buy you happiness.
Uh,
the,
it's true.
Validation isn't nothing.
It's not nothing.
It's like,
it's,
you know,
it's steam and the look in people's eyes
and the energies people have ps.
That's what I'm doing.
Like the look of like,
Oh,
you're,
yeah.
I can't,
like you're,
you're,
you're legit.
You and I,
when I,
if I run into you,
if we're passing in the hallway and you
know,
you say,
I love that bed that you're doing.
Like,
ah,
like I'm like,
I know you're really funny guy.
Yeah.
You like my thing.
I get happy.
You telling me that Chris Rock said I'm
a great comic line.
Yeah.
I get happy.
Positive affirmation.
It's real.
And it's like,
as much as I like,
I'm not insecure.
In fact,
like I,
I'm like,
w go up tonight.
Am I worried?
Do I know how to do this?
No.
But you tell me someone who's really
good says I'm good.
It feels good.
You,
you feel like you're in.
And that's what so many of us felt like
we weren't before we became,
by the way,
I like to say that goes away.
Um,
uh,
Ellen Degeneres is,
I shot this netflix commercial with her
and Chris and Seinfeld and,
uh,
Dave and,
um,
and uh,
so we,
me and eleanor like buddies now and
she's doing a new hour and she sent me
15 minutes of it on DVD.
It like she doesn't fuck with computers.
She doesn't email in,
which is like smart.
She,
I mean,
not like shut the fuck.
She's like,
she just doesn't it.
Yeah.
Um,
she doesn't like,
she'll text on her phone,
she'll,
she'll answer and whatever.
But,
um,
she sent me the f her 15 minutes on a
DVD and I watched it at like midnight on
a Thursday and didn't text her,
cause I don't know when she goes to
sleep and I woke up to a text from her
going like,
Hey,
did you watch it
right?
And I was like,
yeah.
She's like,
I'm starting to get at a,
she's like,
and I go,
yes.
I was like,
Ellen,
you're fucking hilarious.
And she wrote like,
phew,
it never ends.
Never ends,
never ends.
It can't end if it ends,
you know,
it's like I've talked about this before,
that that dream of retirement,
that sailing off into the sunset is
straight on the horse.
It's horse shit.
Yeah.
You want to do good stuff and the only
way to do good stuff is to worry whether
or not you're doing good stuff.
Yeah.
That's the main,
or I,
again,
I'm trying to balance the desire to do
good stuff and not,
and having a good life.
You know what I mean?
You have to have balls because that's
the,
the other thing that happened was like
when like when Charlie Murphy died this
year,
I was like [inaudible] fucking that's
like that was it.
Yeah.
That's that.
That's it.
That's the end of him.
And like I want all I could think of was
did he have fun?
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like did he have fun?
Cause that's really the only thing that
matters.
All this stuff of like,
even the best known comic isn't,
I mean you're like,
people don't think about Carlin that
much anymore.
Do you know what I mean?
Like he matter,
it doesn't
in matters to the people that you affect
in a positive way,
but ultimately for you,
you live and then you die and are,
are you enjoying being alive and those
uncomfortable things,
do they help you like the uncomfortable
things about Ellen,
like view,
what that's going to do is going to
allow her through that weird sort of
anxiety and insecurity.
It's going to allow her to make an
amazing special.
Yeah.
And the same thing can be said of us.
My,
I'm one,
I'm going to film in April.
I'm fucking terrified of writing a new
act cause this act,
when I first started it a year ago,
it was like on Bambi legs and it was dog
shit and I would do it at the store and
I would have bits that would just be
clunky and they'd come out awkward and
then they started to take life after a
month or so and then they started to
grow and bill till it was something that
I could take on the road.
And now that I've gone through that
whole process,
the idea of tossing them aside and
starting all over again,
it's like,
yes,
this is terrifying.
But that's the only way you get better.
Yeah.
By the way,
Ellen did like a half hour at Largo and
then she didn't half hour of a q and a.
And when I say this motherfucker
murdered this month,
I mean it was like God damn,
like sh like,
oh,
that's the funniest thing she could have
said followed by that being the funniest
thing.
She like literally like in a fucking,
they was like watching someone in a
fight just like,
ah,
like q and a and fucking murder and the
people yelling things out though.
It was just like,
Ellen,
I have an agenda.
And she's,
she was funny.
She was mean
because she doesn't fucking comic.
She's like,
you know what I mean?
Like she can write,
you don't write jokes from kindness
stokes from agitation and have to tell
people that.
Yeah.
Uh,
but she's like,
she like even people that worked on her
on her talks over like Jesus that was
like magic,
just like God damn grade talk shows
sensor,
you know,
give her an option to just do something
like that.
Yeah.
You're going to see what she's really
capable of and she's capable of being
very charming and fun.
Super true.
Like that's what the show mostly is
like.
It's mostly just like doing it ge,
she's just sweet.
Yeah.
And then it's a comic.
She's not,
it's not just sweet.
He can't be,
it can't be,
it's literally your,
you can't do comedy.
It's just I do that.
I do that.
Stand up on the spot show.
You've done that before.
I did it Tuesday night.
I said something to someone I could
look,
I go,
I'm going to be mean.
I could understand that.
I don't mean this,
but when you say something stupid I have
to attack you.
You have to be sacrificed for the
greater good of the show.
As long as you're cool with that.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
That's just the way it,
and it's not like she's not like a dark
hearted person or whatever and it's like
that's just kind of,
yeah.
Who,
and she,
you know,
she,
we all have this fear of like,
can I do it again?
It's jumping.
You're jumping over your do your evil
knievel.
Yeah.
And it's like you,
there really is like a fear of like,
can I clear the,
can I clear the chasm?
And you are literally only as good as
your last set.
Yeah.
If you bomb like you better get up on
stage quick and fix it.
Hurt Shit
stands for 20 hours to get back up there
and fix that.
Yeah,
side effects may you literally
will sting for that shit doesn't and I
don't think it gets better,
doesn't get better.
It gets worse because then the people
come to see you.
They expect more of you.
You have higher expectations.
You should know better.
You should know,
but I know about it.
The bomb,
what the hell is your problem?
How you bombing still?
But the thing is,
man,
that develop
mine of material must be done in front
of an audience.
I mean I've write on a computer and on a
notebook,
but the only way it really works out is
in front of a crowd.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's no that's,
if it's not,
if they don't laugh,
it's not comedy.
You don't really know for sure where the
beats are.
You think you've got a pretty good
roadmap from all your experience,
but until you do it in front of a live
audience,
they're there to tell you.
So malanie just did this a mark twain
thing for Letterman.
The,
it was like the Mark Twain Prize and pbs
for David Letterman.
So it's like Steve Martin,
just Bill Murray,
everybody and John Malaney is doing it.
So He sends me his uh,
speech,
his like his bit and uh,
I'm reading it and it's whatever.
I'm like,
Hey,
like whatever.
Couple ideas.
And then,
uh,
so I watch it and he did align that like
killed like immediate,
like one of those things where they
laugh for a split second and then
immediately applaud
like fuck labbing right.
We have to go immediately to applause.
So,
and I was watching this and I was like,
I didn't even know that was a joke.
Like when I read it,
I was like my name though.
That was a joke.
So I texted Malanie I go,
did you,
was that a punchline to you?
And he goes,
nope,
I had no idea.
Two guys with a lot of experience,
no fucking idea.
And it got to like pause,
break like the bet,
the highlight of his part.
That's so didn't even know it was a
joke.
That's the,
and that's what an audience does that
you can't like,
oh,
now we're doing comedy.
I thought that was a straight,
I thought that was a,
just a metaphor.
You know,
I have an APP on my phone,
the uh,
sound app,
the voice notes App,
and when I,
you can look at it and you can edit the
voice notes.
And when you do,
when you go into the edit mode,
you can see the spikes.
And so I'm going over this one bit and I
look and there's this giant fucking
spike in this,
uh,
this Harvey Weinstein bit that I have.
And then I realized that the giant spike
is something that I didn't even know as
a punchline when I wrote it.
I was trying to set something else,
but the way it played out,
it got the biggest fucking laugh of the
entire bit.
And then you have to act like you meant
to do that,
like that whole thing.
And I'm like,
how the fuck did that?
And then I got off stage and Tony
Hinchcliffe said he'd go do that fucking
line.
It's so funny.
I'm like,
man,
I didn't even know what it was going to
be you.
No,
I can't
with saying I w I there is,
you did a thing that I was like that's a
fucking,
oh,
the thing I like that you said about,
it's like sometimes just like rapist,
just look like rape.
Oh,
that's what you're doing.
I'm hardly doing that.
But yeah,
like I say,
you shouldn't judge a book by its cover,
but he wrote some thinks you're dead,
right?
Yeah,
I got it looks like you've rate look
sick fucking total piece of shit.
I mean what a trap it would be if you
look like that and you weren't a piece
of shit and you're like,
I'm a nice guy.
I'm the sweetest guy ever.
Uh,
yeah.
So there's no,
there's literally no knowing what you
know until you do it.
Like there's no,
it's a weird art form in that regard.
You know,
I was talking to Chris Stapleton about
that.
I was,
you know,
I was saying you write all your music
and then you perform it to the audience.
It's done.
And I'm like,
for a comic,
like that's so rare.
It's so rare that I write a bit that
comes out perfect.
Yeah.
And then I bring it to the stage and it
literally mirrors what I wrote down.
Yeah.
I mean sometimes,
but it's never,
there's also a thing,
I was reading something or listening to
something where like your brain
adrenaline will make your brain
do different shit meaning,
so you need to put your,
you need to that address.
Like you can have the map,
you can have your plan,
but then adrenaline will be like,
it's like you ever watch somebody,
uh,
Dave did something.
Did you say that?
DEF Comedy Jam 25th Anniversary.
So it's not very good,
but it's on that flex.
But here's the good,
it's not very good.
There's a sequence where Chappelle and
deal,
he uglier on
and Chappelle is so fucking funny.
It's truly breathtaking and he's
improvising the whole thing and it's
like so fucking breathtaking.
And I was there with Jimmy Carr,
the comedian.
I was like,
this is like when I'm impressed by
David's,
like he must,
cause I fucking know him.
Some of them was like this motherfucker
like,
and he's like,
yes,
but don't discount.
Don't assume that you couldn't have done
something because adrenaline does make
your brain do shit.
It kind of makes it like superhuman and
super like,
like make logic leaps that you wouldn't.
But I um,
in my,
in my line of work and like my eye,
that's going to be 10% ultimately of
like it's 90% written and then I'll 10%
say come up with some on stage.
Yeah.
Um,
when I'm intoxicated,
um,
uh,
more willing to take these big leaps
and,
and go into new rooms,
they're like,
take new new pass office stuff.
Like I'll take a wild,
especially marijuana,
like there's something about being high.
Whereas if I'm doing a bit and
especially a new bit where I'll go,
well,
what about his mom?
The fuck,
how's his mom feel about this?
Yeah.
That bitch has got to be like,
what did I do?
You know?
And then you'll have this whole nother
angle that it's almost like in the
moment it shows itself and then you have
to chase it down.
You have to have the courage,
chase it down,
live in front of a bunch of people that
paid to hear you talk.
Yeah.
And that's the risk you kind of,
that's where a hubris comes in.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's where it's like,
yeah,
I don't know.
I know you paid.
Yeah.
Ah,
well this is how it's got to be done.
Yeah.
One of the good things about comedy
today is because of all these kinds of
conversations that we have,
people sort of understand the process
and particularly quality store.
Yeah.
They want to see the process play out.
Like I've talked to a guy the other day
that was like,
uh,
I came to see you while you were doing
that Bruce Jenner thing and I saw it
through all its incarnations.
I saw the early part was kind of clunky
and then I saw where it became the
finished thing,
which is your clothes and bid on the
special.
And he was like,
I saw you over a period of like three
times over eight months.
He was like,
it was really interesting.
Yeah.
Like they like it.
They're comping nerds.
Yeah.
Yes.
Ship held.
Thinks that's because of alternative
comedy.
He believes that one of the great things
about alt comedy was it brought people
into the process.
I think he's right.
I think it's all it's that in podcasts.
Yeah.
I think podcasts more so cause obviously
way more people listen to podcasts and
go to see alternative comedy shows.
I mean if you have one or two
alternative comedy shows in the city,
it's a big deal.
Like in La,
I mean how many are going on at night?
Three.
So you've got like what 900 people maybe
that are seeing alternative comedy and a
night.
Whereas podcasts thousands and thousands
and thousands if not millions and
millions.
I think that there's a bunch of things
going on though too.
It's like when you become a fan of it,
like I'm a fan of music and I don't
really like one of the things about
having Chris Stapleton and I just wanted
to ask him like how do you write jokes?
Like where they come from.
I always ask that.
It's such a dumb question but it's like
I don't have any idea what that's like.
I mean,
I said jokes,
I meant songs.
Yeah.
Um,
how do you know,
where does the music come from?
Do you have like a beat in your head?
I mean,
and his answer was there's a bunch of
different ways he does it.
You know,
sometimes you just sit in his car and
the thought just comes to him and he
starts singing into his phone.
Yeah.
You know?
That's the,
the uh,
Malanie did a joke or it's like an
anecdote in his act,
so I won't,
I won't blow it,
but like Mick Jagger was hosting snl and
some Malania was writing a song with him
and uh,
Malanie pitched something and Mick
Jagger goes
know,
like,
and he goes,
not fun a wow.
It's like of like of lateral movement.
He's like,
yes,
but it's like,
okay.
I guess the songwriting
blogger,
you could kind of just say whatever the
fuck you want.
Yeah.
I mean,
you're like a seven year old man who
just had a baby.
Yeah.
Shooting loads into models and Brazil
and all over the world.
He just does whatever the fuck
do you find.
Speaking of which,
cause I was saying to somebody,
the in,
in light of like the Cosby,
you know that thing where people become,
I was saying like,
I always say,
beware of a moral arbiter.
Anyone who hold him to be aware of a
moral pillar cause why are you doing
this?
Right.
And why,
like what benefit,
you're not doing it for society.
You're not trying to benefit,
you're not trying to sell the good word.
You're not,
you're literally just being soupy of
superior dickhead.
Right.
Which was cosby's move 100%.
Do you think,
have you noticed what,
what adulation has done to your
personality?
Have you noticed a little creep?
Have you noticed that creep of like,
oh I've,
that,
that's Shitty or you know what I mean?
I don't,
and by the way,
I'm not saying this like,
cause I can think of what Joe,
I'm just saying like are there moments
where you're like,
oh,
like,
cause I don't know,
I'm,
you're,
you're more popular than,
you know what I mean?
Like,
than I am.
So I'm just wondering like have you
noticed anything uh,
happening then you were like,
yeah.
It's interesting.
You gotta be careful of it for sure.
Yeah.
I think I felt it a lot more when I was
younger or uh,
you know,
just dumber.
I think you're,
you're just always aware.
The worst thing that you could do as a
comic is lose your objectivity.
Objectivity.
You have let it slip away instead of let
it increase.
I think in order to be a good comic,
you have to be introspective.
It's Africa until it's very subjective.
Yeah.
Until you're sure of it.
Right.
And then it's like,
no,
fuck you.
Right.
That's where that he was going to then.
Yeah,
I man,
she think perspective,
you know?
I mean that's one of the reasons why I
like pot because it makes me insecure.
Yeah.
Legitimately I like,
I liked that Dana emery or ability and
ever like insecure define insecure
vulnerability,
like insecure about the future,
about life itself.
About like realizing like,
wow,
I can any moment now.
Fucking earthquake can happen at any
moment.
Now we get hit by an asteroid.
The cells in my body literally only have
about 50 years will left of life,
if I'm lucky.
Yeah.
If everything works out great,
you know,
all that stuff.
I'm worrying about my children,
worrying about my family,
worrying about,
you know,
all those things are real.
You know,
that,
those sort of vulnerabilities there are
highlighted by marijuana.
The,
the awareness of your own imminent
demise and just life itself being so
fucking Uber Bizarre.
Like all those are highlighted
by marijuana and which is one of the
things I like about it,
that ruthless introspective quality of
pot that people call paranoia.
I get paranoid.
Well,
I just think that's hyper awareness,
which is why like hugs feel so good when
you're high.
If you're high and you hug somebody,
like,
oh,
give me a hug.
Like I just feel so much better.
It feels so warm.
Like food feels better.
It's like you're way more aware.
I work out.
Hi.
One of my favorite things to do is I did
it yesterday.
I had this meeting here.
I did a podcast and then have to a
meeting.
Um,
uh,
I had like two hours before the meeting
so I smoked a joint and I hit the bag.
I just went over to the heavy bag and it
worked out for like 45 minutes.
And just man,
it's like you're so aware of all the
muscle tissue moving you like feel your
body different.
It like,
especially for me,
like for martial arts techniques,
I really,
I'm really aware of the correct way to
utilize leverage and weight.
It all comes together.
It's just hyper awareness that
hyperawareness also makes you like hyper
focused on yourself and your flaws and
the way you interact with people.
I all,
I never feel confident when I smoke a
lot of pot.
I always feel vulnerable and I always
feel like I should apologize to people
for something.
It's always like something that happened
like a month ago.
Like,
oh,
I was I a dick.
You feel like a woman basically.
Exactly.
Feel emotional or more vulnerable in
woman.
Constantly apologetic.
Well that's one of the reasons why a lot
of fun,
but don't think of marijuana as being a
manly thing.
You know,
marijuana is like very feminine and a
lot of ways very nurturing.
It's really a community sort of a drug
in the sense that it's not something you
want to be by herself with.
It's something you want to be like with
a community of friends.
It's been,
it makes you very,
it makes you,
it's a friendly drug.
Yeah.
That's what I realized.
I didn't,
I never really,
I've gotten drunk.
I got drunk in 2005 and I realize like,
oh,
this is the value I,
what I realized is it's all of us sit in
a,
in a row boat and we just slowly shoot
holes in the boat and we all just slowly
sink at the same,
we're just getting dry and you're just
sinking and sinking,
but you're doing it together.
So it's like nice.
And that's what it sounds like.
You're describing weed.
It's like,
well Duh.
Being honorable,
collected,
all the alcohol is going to come at a
price.
There's no real price for the weed.
Yeah.
For me at least I don't have the price
when it's over,
I feel fine.
Like,
I don't feel like,
like,
oh my God,
my head's pounding.
What the fuck did I do last night like
that,
that I got drunk with my buddies thing.
We had the best time,
we were laughing and high five and,
and howling and crying,
laughing.
But then the next morning like,
oh my God,
your head is fucking pounding pot
doesn't give you that part,
you know?
Yeah.
What was the,
um,
so you had gone through a series of
ketamine there.
Oh yeah,
I did.
Uh,
I did the tms.
The,
uh,
cause I was looking to at the last time
was here was [inaudible] mag,
transcranial magnetic stimulation and
which worked that men,
the problem was,
and I think,
I don't know if I talked about on here
and not,
I h someone gave me some hgh.
Did they tell you that human growth
hormone?
Yeah,
basically.
So I did tms,
which transcranial magnetic stimulation,
45 sessions.
It worked great.
Like it literally has stuck taking,
it takes like 35 minutes and they just
put like electrodes on you or something?
Yeah,
I think I have video.
Um,
they put,
uh,
um,
the,
yeah,
they put video on,
uh,
looking at Chris Rock sends me every
single uh,
uh,
rape thing.
Oh my God.
Everything that comes in every sink,
every page six f literally he sent me 25
of these.
I don't know,
it's just like a thing now because then
we go like,
it's just like a ticket.
So for the morning there's so many guys,
Mario Batali,
and by the way,
the more salacious they can make these
stories,
the better.
They were talking about some room that
Mario would take people up to and the
third floor was the rape.
Like what in the fuck.
All that makes me laugh is the,
the uh,
you know,
it makes me laugh is the um,
the pictures of Louis got progressively
worse and worse.
Oh,
the ones that get fined like the New
York Times,
I was waiting for them to just put up a
picture of Lee Harvey Oswald fucking
hits.
You don't have to find the Shitty
shittiest.
The guilty is looking picture of,
there's so much video of him beating off
like air beating off,
you know,
play that video.
This,
this is you guys the last time I was
here,
this is on the line.
Yes.
From last time you were here.
Yeah.
Wow.
Look at that man.
Give me some volume knowing about it.
I went to this.
Whoa dude,
that sound is like an Mri.
That's what it is.
Yes,
that's right.
We talked about last week,
um,
the uh,
but uh,
case.
So then the problem was after that I did
hgh for someone gave me some hgh and I
was like,
yeah,
I'll fucking take you.
I don't give a shit.
Yeah,
I'll take a shit.
I'm always looking for an advantage.
And I started having panic attacks from
Hga.
Yes.
Which is a,
we,
it's a narrow side effect,
but it's one of the side effects of hgh.
Basically.
It like supercharged my whole system.
I started having panic attacks on stage.
I had a panic attack the night before.
I take three mikes.
Why couldn't go onstage?
Spade was supposed to bring me on and I
told Adam,
I was like,
I can't go on.
I literally couldn't breathe well night
before.
Yeah,
it was,
thankfully it did.
Yes.
I thankfully didn't get one that night.
Like,
oh my God,
dude,
trust me,
trust me.
And then I,
and then I had anxiety for months.
Literally like,
just like when people say I have
anxiety,
I had never had,
it was like,
I'm not an
anxious person.
I wouldn't even know what that's like.
Wow.
It's fucking miserable.
It's,
to me it was worse than depression
because you're agitated and like you
just feel like static.
It just was like a static over your
body.
It was like,
you're,
you just have like this,
like cortisol,
snow in your,
and it's sucked.
So I went back on a,
on a Zoloft,
um,
to,
and then it ended the anxiety now.
But you are trying to get yourself off
of that stuff.
So now I'm going to go,
I'm,
I'm back on,
I just stopped taking it all off like
two weeks ago.
How did you can't,
I feel actually really good because,
oh,
here's what I didn't say.
I also micro dosed do,
uh,
while it was on Zoloft,
I microdose shrooms,
uh,
like three times,
which is actually like pretty fun.
It's Super Fun,
but it's like not daunting.
It's not that you're not like,
it's not trippy,
right?
You're not like,
oh yeah,
you just feel good.
Uh,
I did that three times a did lsd once
and I,
I'm thinking of,
so now I'm going off and,
and,
and interesting happened when I
microdosed I got significantly less
angry just as like an operating
principle.
Like I was just like,
oh,
I'm less angry.
Like I just didn't feel as like snappy
and shitting like for a long,
for like a,
like an a b over big period.
I've got a buddy of mine who's a world
champion kickboxer he mocked her doses
and he fights on,
it fights high on mushrooms.
Do they test for it or they,
it's just,
nope,
that's fine.
I fucking people up while he's on
mushrooms.
That's great.
And I mean better than he's ever looked
in his past.
He said he could see things coming
before they happen.
Yup.
He said literally feels like he's got
some sort of psychic ability when he's
sparring,
like he sees what guys are doing and if
you watch him fight,
he just looks way sharper than he's ever
looked before at home.
Boys doing mushrooms.
Yeah.
Then that's the,
so I've been,
I stopped taking it the love because you
can't,
uh,
you can't be on it.
And do I have a game?
Uh,
you can,
uh,
you risk serotonin syndrome,
which is like it too much serotonin in
your body or yeah.
Yeah.
So we're the first guy that tell me
about five htp before we even started
selling it at all,
before we started having a mood.
You were telling me about five htp and
that you were sandy.
Dan told me about no shit.
Yeah.
Cause I,
he saw me some ecstasy and he was like,
yeah,
and also take this the next day.
And it was like,
Oh God.
And then I like research and I was like,
oh,
I should just take.
So I still take that five HDP.
I think it's good for weight loss.
Really.
Um,
it like when I take five htp,
I'm just not hungry.
Um,
it like that was the other sort of weird
side effect of the microdosing my
appetite went down like significantly
across the board.
One,
how much of the appetite is not really
how much food you need,
but rather you need something to do.
Yeah.
Or it's just like at this time of day I
do this.
Um,
but I ended up like losing 10 pounds.
That's interesting to me.
Like 50 firm,
I've lost 12 pounds from like one 59,
nine one 47.
Wow.
Yeah.
But it's not like a,
not starving myself or anything.
Right.
So you didn't feel uncomfortable?
No,
not at all.
He was like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Do you monitor your diet?
Are you,
do,
are you eating healthy?
Yeah.
Like I got my blood tested probably
three months ago and everything was
good.
Do you,
are you eating sugar and bread and
things like I've eaten,
I've stopped.
Uh,
I've eaten.
I used to be a big dessert person and I
kind of just like,
I think the mushrooms might've maybe
just kinda like,
Eh,
you know,
things that you don't,
um,
don't sugar.
You know,
the thing with sugar is you don't need
it for three days if you don't want it.
Right.
Like you just,
your body doesn't like,
you got to fucking get us some sugar.
You're just like,
Eh,
I'm good once you cut free.
Yeah.
And especially if you're really
conscious about what you're eating in
terms of like probiotics and things that
sort of help the landscape,
the biome landscape,
and make sure you've got healthy things
in there.
I think that's so significant.
And the more researchers that I talked
to and the more people that are
nutrition experts to start talking about
your gut biome and how important it is
to take the proper probiotics.
Yeah.
I think it affects your personality.
I think it affects your immune system.
I think it affects virtually the path of
your life that you take depending upon
what foods you eat.
It has a different effect on how you
live your life.
Well,
that's meditation.
Does the same thing cause you're like
you get a feeling for meditation and
then you're like,
do I want to spoil this with like
garbage thinking or behavior like
coming?
Just try to bring a bit of that in here
in my every day.
Yeah.
I mean that's the tank for me.
The tank is literally forgot about tanks
until you and I'm like,
I live like a block from float lab.
You got to go like I,
I went,
I went.
I think you must.
How long have you been doing this?
2002 was the first time I got one.
When,
when did you start doing the podcast?
I think you told me about it.
You told me about it.
I went to float lab.
Had the thought in the,
in the tank.
You got to love something.
Literally that was the thought.
I had an and then I got a dog.
Literally like he's always like,
I fucking,
yeah,
like that,
that I'd like that shit.
Like,
and I just
forget that it exists.
The tanks.
Yeah,
I think they're giant.
I think it's only one of them.
It's,
it's one of those things that requires
you to block off a chunk of your time.
So if you're a busy person,
it's hard to,
yeah,
it's hard to pull that up.
But I think it's like one of the most
important things you could do.
How often you do it?
Well,
I haven't done it a long time because I
took the one out of my basement and I
had it installed here.
Got It.
Took me a few,
a few times off and we just got it put
in two days ago.
So I haven't even been in it.
So I haven't been a tank at all and
three months.
Oh Wow.
Two months,
two months,
something like that.
How often do you think you'll do it now?
A couple of days a week.
A couple days a week is good.
If I give myself two days a week,
I'm happy.
Do you ever go in and just think about
your daughters?
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Like is it,
so it's not,
I don't like have a plan.
Sometimes I have a plan,
like maybe I'll have a bit that I'm
trying to work out and I just like this
bed.
It's just clunky.
There's a part of it that's clunky.
I'll smoke some pot and climbing that
tank and think about it.
There's a in the,
in the,
the,
there's like a pre
fucking syllabus for the Ibogaine and
it's like,
you need to come with questions.
Ooh for Ibogaine,
whoa.
First Sweet Lady Ibogaine.
Whoa.
And it's like,
I have to write.
And then a friend of mine was like,
can you ask a question for me?
It's like,
no,
I don't think that's legal.
Like he'd be like
Kate.
So where Lucy
needs advice or news about what's going
on with her feet?
Oh yeah.
But I'm like looking forward to asking,
asking big questions.
Although I gotta say the last year has
been very revealing for me in terms of
like what,
what's important,
what's valuable.
So how much of an effect did having a
dog have on you getting a dog,
something you love and you come home
too?
Probably like 15,
20%.
He's just a fucking good dude to have
around.
Yeah.
Do you see that there was an article a
couple of weeks ago about dogs are so
inbred that they're basically retarded.
They have some wheat,
Jamie,
when you look it up cause it's,
they have some,
we've just aunt just piles and piles and
piles and generations of integrating
that they have this disease that's
tantamount to down syndrome that all
dogs have this.
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
Um,
other than,
yeah,
I would assume other than like German
shit,
like the most highly trained German
shepherds are like,
I'm not like them
got a golden retriever that's a year old
now.
And when I come home like,
uh,
he's the only one that's awake,
you know,
I'll come home from the store and you
know,
everybody else is asleep and I come home
much
my dude
and he's running around me and the
mining and kissing me and
yeah,
just like good.
Feels good.
Just like good fucking good dude.
Yeah.
I take him running.
I love doing that.
And he loves it.
Oh,
he loves it.
He gets so excited.
He hates going to my truck.
But he'll go up to the truck like he
knows and then Mike come on in.
He won't hop in himself,
but I'll pick them up.
Like he knows he's going to have a good
time once he gets in there.
Yeah.
How long is the ride?
Uh,
just a few minutes.
It's not that bad.
Does he throw up?
If it's longer it,
he'll,
I've taken him on a 20 minute ride
before and eventually it'll chuck he's,
he gets,
he gets car sick.
Did you see that picture of somebody's
tape took a selfie while their dog was
throwing up?
Holy Shit.
Business.
Funny
Golden retrievers though,
man.
He's the first golden retriever I've
had.
They are lovely dogs there are so sweet.
They're just like bundles of affection
and happiness and he's smart man.
Yeah.
Like he's,
he's really easy to train.
He wants you to like him.
He wants you to be happy.
And so like when he finds the things
that you will be happy about,
he,
you know,
he gravitates towards those.
Yeah.
That's,
hold on.
There's such good dogs,
man.
I mean,
I've had a bunch of different kinds of
dogs in my life and I'm a big dog fan,
but I'm just particularly impressed with
golden retrievers.
Just so nice.
And he's so great with my kids too.
That's the other thing.
He just a big,
big love.
But my dog,
we've got Jamie.
Oh my God.
That picture is hilarious.
She caught the dog.
Maybe made her God damn hard.
Oh my God,
my dog threw up while I was taking a
selfie.
The Gal's name.
It's not,
uh Oh,
okay.
A repost.
Yeah.
Oh,
there's a few.
Is it,
what does it say up there?
Lie like a light l y kke underscore L.
I uh,
that's a fucking hilarious meme.
God Damn it.
That made me laugh.
So that is pretty fucking funny.
Um,
what kind of dog yet?
Pitbull.
Oh,
there was another thing when,
you know what else helps
with negative thoughts is a thing called
a murder.
Uh,
he kills homeless people for you.
Cognitive behavioral therapy.
Um,
and it was basically like,
it's
this,
this made me laugh.
Like it,
it's so dead on.
They just have think it's cool.
Just an unhelpful thinking styles.
Uh,
Jimmy,
you can bring this up to actually,
uh,
there's a chart.
One of them is all or nothing thinking a
or black and white thinking something
like,
if I'm not perfect,
I've failed.
Either I do it right or not at all.
Just like dumb shit.
So anytime I think these things,
there's going to know you're
disqualified.
Like you gotta go.
Okay.
A mental filter only paying attention to
certain types of evidence.
Uh,
noticing our failures,
but not seeing our successes.
Jumping to conclusions.
Yeah.
Um,
hmm.
Thinking over generalizing everything
always rubbish.
No comedy ever happens.
A lot of these are literally just like
comedy.
How do you make comedy?
Yeah.
You have to exaggerate jumped to
conclusions yet,
but they're re they can be really
destructive on a personal level.
You know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
For sure.
But
I think everybody needs something
difficult to do on top of what they
already do.
This is my theory about standup comedy.
Uh,
one of the,
one of the ways that I've sort of
tighten up my game over the last few
years is to concentrate on difficult
things outside of comedy.
You know,
whether it's martial arts or whether
it's a yoga or bow hunting is another
one for me.
Doing things that are very difficult
makes comedy a little bit easier.
How come?
Because it's relatively easier.
Yeah.
Relatively easier.
But also you recognize like just didn't
do,
it doesn't seem like bow hunting and
standup comedy would ever go together,
but the way they go together as,
as an absolute reality in bow hunting
and it's fucking really difficult to do.
And in doing that,
it just helps you manage the
difficulties of standup better.
The same thing with Jujitsu.
I felt like Jujitsu helped me a lot with
stand up and martial arts in general
because Jujitsu is so much more
difficult to do than comedy.
Like physically difficult.
Like as you're doing it,
you're groaning and strengthen and,
and straining and just barely,
barely surviving certain situations and
getting into positions where people are
literally squeezing your fucking neck
and hear about to blackout.
Yeah.
And it just makes the uncomfortable
feeling of anticipation of standup.
It just makes it less dangerous.
Like less scary.
I did a show last night at the Fonda,
so it's like,
uh,
you know me theater,
so to speak,
audience probably,
I don't know,
800 people or something.
And by Dennis spot on Tuesday night
length.
Right.
I've done spots every night for the last
10 years in some degree of decent and
the thoughts I was having before I went
on like,
like,
no,
you're going to throw up on her,
like you're going to have a bad back
throw up on yourself.
And then I'm on stage.
I'm like,
why did you think that was going to
happen?
Fucking Weirdo.
I'm like,
none of it even came close to happening,
but your brain's just like,
no,
no.
He got to,
this is going to like this worst case
scenario.
Shit that's so impractical.
The other thing that,
you know what's great and horrible at
Santa,
but somebody was saying like,
uh,
yeah,
you can't compare your spot.
You're set somebody else's and it's
like,
I can't not,
I heard the lapsed they got right.
Yeah,
I want
to get those labs or better.
Yeah.
Or you definitely can have some bombs.
In the other's audience socks and you go
up there and they're great.
Yeah.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Like I have to compare like I can't,
like it's impossible not,
I can't act like it didn't,
businesses can't go like,
oh,
don't worry about that guy across the
street to know exact same business as a
theater.
Roosevelt comparison is the thief of
joy.
Yes.
Yeah.
But good luck following that shit.
Good luck following the,
I mean we all have to fucking,
you ever stick around just to see what
the next guy gets garbage.
Just see what,
uh,
I do,
but I tried to do it in a pure way.
I try to do it as a comedy fan.
Trying to still be a comedy fountain.
Yes.
I've done that.
I,
it's nine.
It's nine to one.
Like doing it as a fan,
like most of the time,
especially at the store.
Like I want to see the person on after
it's a stores,
oddly supportive.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Cause I never feel like if I catch a bad
one,
I never feel judged by the guy I just
brought up.
Well that's another thing about,
we were talking about this the other
day,
can you catch a bad one at the store?
And everybody sort of wants to like
commiserate with you.
Like,
oh dude,
last week I couldn't get a laugh to say
my fucking life.
And everybody wants to,
it's not like everyone knows like the
level of comedy there is so high that
everyone knows that everyone's legit.
Yeah.
So it's like not like,
oh neal Brennan's losing it.
Like all right,
he's trying not to miss the shuck and
bum.
Yeah,
he's a fucking,
it was his turn.
Yeah.
And there are just moments followed Erik
Griffin probably a month ago and he
caught a bad one and I went,
uh,
Erik Griffin,
one of the worst spots he's had and a
couple of months.
It's fucking,
they laugh.
We all just like,
yeah,
I had that was made three days ago down.
Sometimes it's no,
not pretty,
and it,
no one is immune,
especially in the or the or the original
room.
That room we'll fucking slap you in the
face with reality.
Like no other room in the country,
although I have more bad sits in the
main room that I do in the Olr.
Do you?
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
I don't,
I don't even really know.
I feel like the main,
the or like suits me better because I
don't have to be like gregarious and did
it,
it you can just be like fucking,
you can be,
you can creep.
Yeah.
You can be a dark creep
and you can be a dark creep in that or
yeah.
But it's,
uh,
it's also think,
I think it's incredibly valuable to have
that many high level comics around you
all the time.
Yeah.
See that level and be inspired and like,
oh Jesus,
that's a good joke.
They're like,
fuck it and what not even fuck,
why didn't I think of it?
I'm jealous.
Just like,
you know,
it's a good first.
Nailed it.
They nailed it.
They give it to him.
That's a fair fair.
And he did it fair and square.
The only time I don't feel those like
God fucking now that,
why didn't I think of that?
The only time I don't think like that is
what I'm doing enough writing when I'm
doing plenty of writing.
Those creepy like jealousy thoughts
don't get in there.
Yeah.
We're the,
you know,
the whimsical a co could have been me if
I just got there first.
And it isn't,
it is that,
it is golf in that it's as much as you
can here.
The guy in front of you
sink a long Putt,
you still got it's you against you.
It's still like,
oh,
for sure doesn't mean because you
killed.
Doesn't mean I can't write of course.
But if you think you can't,
it does mean you can't.
Yes.
Oh,
I know.
I can tell you a hour before my set how
I'm going to do,
I'm not even kidding.
I can just tell
by my,
like my,
uh,
my serotonin level.
Do you ever try to break yourself out of
it?
Yes.
They're,
the positive visualization is good.
And,
uh,
and just like taking a moment and like
trying to get some serotonin going and
like feel,
just try to feel good
for me.
I moved my body around like bounce
around and place like a jump around.
Like I'll stretch and just get
everything moving my head.
Yeah,
I've done that still shadowboxing.
Just shuffle my feet,
cause get my blood pumping and get
everything accelerating.
Another thing that no one judges,
no one goes like the fuck is Rogan.
Do you know what I mean?
Like no one at the store would be like,
we all just like,
I've been in conversations with people.
If someone goes,
hey,
I gotta get ready.
I'm not,
yeah bro.
Can't just walk up there man.
Bro.
One Time Joey Diaz yelled at me for
having a notebook.
You know,
Joey's just get that weird thing like
every now and then like what are you
doing with fucking ketchup and fries?
Fries,
taste great on the road.
You don't need no fucking ketchup.
Like every now and then he'd just get
crazy with some like absolute.
And I had a notebook and he goes,
what the fuck he doing with that
notebook?
I go,
I'm working on some new shit.
He goes,
you're carrying around that fucking
notebook.
Like those other memos that just want
you to know that they're fucking
writing.
I know.
Book.
Yeah.
Get the fuck Outta here with notebooks
and notebooks,
Joe.
Yeah.
Joey,
is that where it is now?
This is important.
I remember shit literally calf to
remember.
Shit.
I have all these new punchlines.
I have to,
I don't want to fuck this up.
Yeah.
You know,
what the fuck are you doing?
Come on dog.
The fucking notebook out of here that I
can talk about.
Uh,
talk about hearing what the guy in front
of you gets.
You can't following him.
It's just like,
okay,
you guys want some fucking thoughtful
notions.
Uh,
that's how I
phil after him,
I feel like I might as well go up as
like a fucking professor.
There's,
we'll have like a briefcase,
like good evening class.
Well,
that's one of the reasons why I started
taking joey on the road with me just
cause I was scared to follow him.
Yeah.
I know also wanted the best I could work
with.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I've had people come out to see me.
I don't want to be the only one.
Funny.
I want to,
I want everybody else to be funny too is
I'd bring the best guys I could and I
realized that that you just gotta be
able to ride the wave of Joe.
That's the,
that it's like that with anybody.
The avant had to follow Chappelle the
other night and he was like,
I didn't,
I,
I was like scared.
And I was like,
yeah,
you don't be there.
So gacked from seeing somebody that
famous that they're like,
they just don't fuck with it.
Yeah.
If you're comfortable,
you could ride the way.
But if you are insecure because Oh my
God,
I just go,
I'm going after Joey Diaz Shit and that
nervousness and that feeling.
I took joy in the road of me once in New
Jersey and I bombed.
It was like the last time I bombed going
on after Joey and uh,
he went up and fucking murdered and he
was fucking with the crowd.
Like I forget what happened,
but I remember that feeling as I was
going up to the stage,
like this is not going to be good.
I don't want to have all given me.
And it was a transitionary period in my
act where I was like not quite can have
the bits down yet.
It's still working.
[inaudible]
Yup.
But that's one of the reasons why I used
to love taking them with,
I can't anymore because it's too
successful.
But I would still love,
that's a rock rock does that rock.
If rocks done a weekend when he first
had his new hour,
he,
he like,
he's like,
I gotta get earthquake out here man.
He's like,
I need good sparring partners.
I need people that are like fucking,
I'm afraid to follow.
He's like,
I get earthquake and Leslie out here,
earthquake will murder our room.
Yeah,
you don't even know.
It's one of those things where he's
already murdered them when he gets out
for like it's all so for high level it's
insane.
He also had a thing,
his last special,
he fucked a joke up and kept it in.
Oh really?
And it's like,
oh y'all never fucked up.
It's fucking really funny history.
Really.
That dude is fucked up a joke.
Uh,
like,
which is like a hag.
It's a hacky thing to say other than he,
the way he did it was so fucking,
that's very smart of him to do that.
To bring those guys with them.
Yes.
Murder after murderer that's wise.
And then you have to fucking,
you have,
then you can't be like no.
Cause it's like I don't care about fame.
I don't,
I didn't know who that person was
and he's fucking hilarious.
Well that in is not just about comedy
and I think that relates to a lot of the
problems that a lot of people have in
life with what you would call haters.
Like with a lot of haters are,
as they see people that are doing way
better than them,
they see things that are happening and
there's some things legitimately to
hate.
Right.
But then there's a lot of haters that
are haters about athletes or about
singers or rappers or whatever.
A lot of it is just jealousy and the
that jealousy is,
they look at themselves,
they look at that person,
they don't like the way they measure up.
And so all they can concentrate on is
trying to find something wrong with that
person.
Like try
and not being instead inspired.
Yeah.
You know,
and like being inspired is so much more
beneficial to you.
It's so much healthier and it's so much
more of a strong move.
Yeah.
It doesn't,
you're not having,
I think a lot of times with this like
Harvard,
then it goes to that power thing.
I think some guys,
sometimes guys especially we'll see that
see their career is revenge.
Oh yeah.
I think there is a little,
a little bit of that is worthwhile,
but I don't,
I think it can poison a fucking chore.
Poison you if you're,
if you're consumed by it.
Cause there's guys that we all know that
are just like,
all they do is like,
just see what so and so got and you're
like,
yeah,
those guys are useless.
Yeah.
It again,
he's not,
it wasn't between you and him and the
taints their work to that mindset that
that limited growth mindset that fucks
with their work.
Yeah.
Trying to be original and as good as you
pause somebody was the other night was
complaining like,
yeah,
my agent didn't.
He moved and he did.
They didn't tell me and I was like,
dude,
every job you ever get is going to be
from other comics.
It's every job,
every job I've ever gotten is from the
Boston comedy club,
comedy cellar and the store literally in
my entire career.
That's crazy.
I mean basically,
uh,
I was videotaping people for casting
director when it worked at the Boston,
got a job out here working for her then.
Then I started working for Niccolo that
we cast MTV singled out.
I got a writing job there.
Next door was nickelodeon.
All that started talking to them.
Got a job there.
Me and Chappelle,
right.
Half baked him I know from Boston.
Um,
then I write movies for a while,
then we do chappelle show still still
from Boston.
Uh,
and then then I'm like in Showbiz and
it's all like a direct,
it's all the direct current from that.
Every commercial I direct commercials,
it's all from,
that's from Chappelle show cause it's
like a long story.
But like the Air Jordan,
I did things with them and then they
were like,
you should do more commercial.
So I do commercial and it's like,
it's all from your peers.
Right.
It's literally offering me periods.
That's it.
That's the only people that are gaining
get you that they're the people that are
going to hire you.
Some people don't like to think that way
because I think there's like this
embedded mindset that used to exist when
there was a limited number of jobs.
Yeah.
And there was like only two guys could,
uh,
you know,
one guy is going to be a competing
against someone else for the tonight
show.
Only one guy's going to get it.
You know,
that's not the case anymore.
There's so much above others.
By the way,
there's too much almost,
I mean there's,
it's too much to keep up with like just
all the Netflix special,
can't watch all this shit.
Like I truly
don't have time.
I don't know how people do it.
Um,
but like the,
that's what it comes down to.
It's like it's not being competitive
with people and supporting people and
being inspired by the people that are
really good fuel.
Yeah.
Like I was telling somebody,
it's a long shot,
but a girl,
I knew a girl I know who is,
is a producer at a TV show and she
hadn't watched my netflix special and
I'm like,
we're friends.
And I was like,
you're,
you're stupid for not watching it.
I go,
hey,
it's insulting to me.
You're directly insulting me.
You're literally just hurting my
feelings going out of your way and I go,
and B,
you're in comedy.
It's a well-regarded thing.
Like just inform yourself.
I was like,
I saw Schumer do a joke nine years ago
that I really liked and just texted her
like it didn't really know her at all.
It was like,
Hey,
that looks fucking great.
And then she asked me to director show,
you know what I mean?
Like,
and I'm not,
I didn't do it to get her to do,
you know what I mean?
It's just this thing of just like,
yeah,
that's how you make relationships.
You just like,
I like that.
Some people don't like watches 10 up
though.
Like north,
that's what she said.
She's like,
I just don't like stand up.
And I was like,
okay.
I was like,
I go,
that's completely fair.
Well,
Norton likes it,
but he doesn't want to be influenced so
he doesn't watch any stand up.
That's fair.
Yeah.
This girl just doesn't,
she's like,
I just like scripted comedy better.
Whoa.
And I was like,
well,
she salt to do she answer bro.
Right to my face.
I can't believe it.
Hey,
I gotta go to the dentist,
go to the fucking dentist,
man.
Give you teeth.
Did.
Yeah.
So,
um,
come back after you do Ibogaine.
Oh,
cannot wait.
How long are you gonna be up there for?
Three or four days.
How many different treatments?
One treatment.
Yeah.
And the other days are just kick it.
Just one day is like you gotta like you
gotta write your questions.
Uh,
one day is like,
it's,
I'm getting there Monday,
do it Tuesday and then that bleed into
Wednesday and maybe 24 hour experience.
Right.
They say 24 to 36.
Ooh.
Uh,
which I'm really,
I watched a bunch of videos.
You know what's funny is so many,
if you go on youtube and just fucking
typing anything,
so much of it comes back to this,
to your show.
Oh No.
In a good way.
Like so and so talks about blank,
like if you,
especially drugs,
um,
like it's,
and there was a lot of,
it was a dude who you've had on here,
I can't remember his name,
but like Spencer's and I don't know.
Um,
but uh,
who had talked about doing Ibogaine and
have you done Iowaska?
No,
haven't done nine wants to,
have you done any emt?
Yeah,
I've done a done mushrooms,
done acid.
Never done a number down.
I began,
but I,
I've always associated,
I began with being a one that people use
to cure the patients.
For sure.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm addicted to the game game son.
I'm trying to get loose from this game.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the great and powerful Neil Brennan
time.
Joe,
until we meet again,
my friend didn't show your Ibogaine
ventures.
See you sooner than these gentlemen.
That was great.